this is 103.3
wxojlp northampton and this is the debut
episode of midweek politics i'm david
pakman our phone number here is 413 so i
want to take this time
to welcome in senator john kerry from
the u.s senate senator kerry thanks for
joining us today
i'm delighted to be with you thank you
it's the week of november 5th 2008 and
we have a new president-elect barack
obama winning in what some are calling a
landslide victory yesterday well we're
we have some cameras in the studio we
did a trial run of this and now we've
actually got what i guess is our debut
episode of the tv version and we're glad
to be on uh not only locally on
northampton cable access tv and of
course on youtube and uh you can
actually see these videos or you might
even be seeing them
right now the healthcare bill has as
most of our audience i'm sure has heard
past it's an okay bill you're listening
to the david pakman show
hey welcome to the show i'm david pacman
that's right it's no longer midweek
politics it's now the david pakman show
so hold on i am getting a thumbs up from
my producer that there has been a
message posted that appears to be from
anonymous on
downloads.westborobaptistchurch.com is
and anonymous are you taking
responsibility for this
yep we just did it right now this very
second all these other sites are down
become
there you go
uh elizabeth warren really great to see
you today and thanks for coming in it's
so nice to see you thank you great thank
you take care have you heard about the
new way to open bananas
yeah you've heard about it pinch the top
instead of the bottom
[Applause]
[Music]
you get the whole thing that way let's
switch to natan now and give him the
tana shout out right so i've got one of
these uh
crickets i guess yeah is what lewisgame
i don't know what it is
[Applause]
it's not too salty okay it's crunchy
louis
you know what day it is
you're doing it right i'm ready what do
you got there t
yeah i got like two hours of sleep
all right it's a great start to election
day
cheers president obama wins mitt romney
was an incompetent candidate he never
had a chance ohio just called for
president obama he won i'm featured in
the movie as a gay teen
that the movie is dedicated to who
committed suicide
i i'm obviously not a teen and the
pictures from when i was 20 something
i'm not gay i wasn't bullied
i'm alive i mean i just don't get what
the hell's going on here cause we've
been speaking with neil degrasse tyson
congratulations on the great book really
enjoyed reading it oh thank you thank
you so here we have this is the debut of
hate mail number two patriot mail
david it's clear to me and probably the
rest of the world name and i want to
bring in david peck when he interviewed
him in 2010 on his radio show and joins
me now and joining us today is rebecca
ann who's a psychic medium and author
you must have some alternative music
taste that i i don't know if i can
understand all the words okay let me
jump in right now
let me jump in right now hold on a
second let's all go one at a time
all of these things are common themes on
the show so so far anybody who listens
to the show would know all the stuff
lewis is in a metal band it's all online
there's videos
and he's coming over now with the durian
and
it is a little bit ranked he has some
plates and he's going to attempt to uh
oh you've already cut it he's bringing
it in
oh my goodness that that is absolutely
rancid
that is really concerning
do you smell that the big news is that
donald trump has won the presidential
campaign and is now the president-elect
of the united states i went to the
mirror that was closest to where i was
at the time and realized that i had a
big red dot on my chin
and i leaned in and got very very close
to the mirror and realized that some of
my beet soup known as borscht that i had
had earlier that day for lunch
apparently had splashed onto my face and
i did the entire show with about a half
inch red dot of dried borscht on my face
dave i guess pat didn't get the memo
that if you use a courage or bring that
[ __ ] up he's going to get hung and beat
up and abused i'm joined today by roger
stone who is a political consultant new
york times best-selling author roger
you're an in-demand guy these days it
seems everybody including people in
government want to talk to you what i do
is i pick up the burger and flip it as i
bring it up to my mouth
right
and the sesame seeds are now on the
bottom
and that's how i bite it and as you can
see the entire tower is teetering and
tottering right now and pat looks so
nervous it's amazing how nervous pat
looks
uh oh no
[Music]
that's it that was it pat looks shocked
at what just took place
melania trump
has liked on twitter
our video questioning how she got an
einstein visa and let's talk about this
with don giordano david pakman radio
host in their respective cities
philadelphia and boston as they are
gentlemen nice to see you the [ __ ]
they feel amazing incredible you like
[ __ ] i'm sorry you like let's i don't
know anything have you ever seen that
word [ __ ]
i don't think so would you date a [ __ ]
it's a pejorative it's not a term i use
amazing it is great to welcome back to
the program today andrew yang who is an
author and entrepreneur and uh notably
most recently running as a democrat for
president in 2020 i genuinely did not
realize that crowder does a comedy show
oh yeah yeah so when he so the show is a
comedy show wow
yeah a lot of it is funny he does some
funny [ __ ] he really does whether you
agree with him or disagree with him he's
done some hilarious bits i genuine i'm
i'm reacting in real time because i had
no idea
um
yeah
i think that's me oh no so i'm gonna go
back on my end actually good game david
very good game the who has now declared
covid19 a global pandemic all right
everybody let's cut it there the full 1
billion view celebration video is going
to be publishing in about 40 minutes
um at the top of the hour
um
and
it's always so strange uh to see people
um on both youtube and twitch saying
that i'm playing the video without audio
of course we are playing it with audio
you might your device might just be
muted but full audio working beautifully
on all platforms as everybody can attest
um i did read that snoop dogg has has
done like three streams in a row with no
audio
it can happen it can happen it's just
not happened on this channel
um the audio was working fine you you
were probably just uh just muted okay
very good i have so many things to tell
people about of course
we did reach one
billion views one
billion views one billion views which is
truly um an incredible incredible number
i need 11 000 votes give me a break so
we did do it we got the number that we
needed we do have a billion view
related coupon code and coupon code
which i will be announcing a little bit
later i also am going to take the
opportunity to mention
this may be a double stream today
because we have two events we have uh in
about 20 minutes
joe biden is scheduled to give a
national address on afghanistan where we
are now out the last soldier officially
leaving yesterday at 11 59 pm
afghanistan time an incredible day
um
and then at 3 30 p.m eastern we are
scheduled to have a gensake
press briefing so
this is a very wide stream and it will
be up to you as to how long it is if you
understand what i'm saying if we do get
to our hundred members and twitch subs
by the end of the biden event we're just
gonna keep going directly into today's
second stream there will be no break
there will be no interruption and it's
going to be uh it's gonna be an
incredible day and historic day i would
say in fact
um what else do i have to update people
on there were no streams last week
because
i was having i was in the bunker due to
a security issue a security threat um
when there's a security threat i go into
the bunker for a full week that was last
week and that the computer in the bunker
is dying it might be it's so deep down
in the ground
that something about the air pressure
may be affecting the computer we
couldn't keep the audio and video synced
so um
i just wasn't able to do any live
streams it would have been a technical
disaster from the standpoint of tech it
would have been a disaster
and of course i was only down there
inspecting the bunker i want to make
sure people know it wasn't
there wasn't really a threat i just
every once in a while i go down and i
spend a week in the bunker just to
inspect it to make sure that everything
looks looks right
um so that's why there were no streams
but i am glad to be back today
uh what's been going on in the garden in
the garden things have been going really
well i had so many lemon cucumbers
actually let me see if i can pull this
up hold on
uh instagram here it is
i have these on one click
yeah here it is
look at this i had so these are all
cucumbers people a lot of people don't
realize cucumbers don't have to be green
and they don't have to be phallic they
can be bulbous instead and these are
lemon cucumbers it smells just like a
cucumber it tastes just like a cucumber
but it's round and yellow
and i have dumped all of them into a
pickling solution okay and in three more
days i'm gonna have pickled lemon
cucumbers so maybe we'll do a taste test
on an upcoming stream that would be
great as you can see the peppers are
really strong these are three different
plants i've got the jalapeno that's the
dark green then there's this kind of in
between it's like it's between a
cubanelle and a jalapeno it's less spicy
and it's less green
and then the biggest one here that is a
just a standard cubanelle great way to
add crunch to a sandwich and then also
my eggplants are on fire
these two eggplants have already been
duly roasted and i have another eggplant
ready to go i'll probably clip it
tomorrow
um
and so that's all going on oh by the way
i want to make sure i also want to give
a shout out josh perry bmx is a follower
of the show you could see he commented
here wicked strong
josh recently had brain surgery okay
really good guy supporter of the show
retired bmx
dude
really good guy and you can follow his
surgery story on his instagram we're
sending him best wishes i sent him a
message the other day
and he said he's just hanging he's just
hanging and so maybe he's even watching
right now but shout out to josh perry
wishing him absolutely the best
but really really strong things
happening in the garden and as far as
fall crops
i checked in with kevin from epic
gardening
and he okayed the planting of cabbage
um
carrots and beets
they've all sprouted i got 100
uh what's it called when you get 100
sprouting on every seed is it like
penetration or is it like it's the
equivalent of click-through rate but on
seeds
um i have two types of beets a a golden
beet
and then your standard purple beet it's
like an heirloom beat
yield we call it yield 100 germination
yeah
um and so i'm expecting in about 55 days
maybe i will do a live stream where i
pop out the beets and the carrots and
it's gonna be really it's amazing
actually i've never grown anything from
seeds so we're starting that
okay so good we're caught up as far as
that goes we are waiting for joe biden
to address the nation on afghanistan
that is stream number one that's this
stream and if we get to 100 website
members and twitch subscribers
oh man we're at 666 on twitch that's
ominous that doesn't bode well
oh if we get to 100 i will just continue
into stream number two which will be a
gensake press briefing
in about an hour okay so that's where we
are today let me get caught up on thank
yous and see where we are on twitch i
want to say thank you to won propen as
well as juargio
kelly voice or x
ryan83
junk saint polo dal
as well as cosmos
milo wild geo-venture brett feinbom as
well that kicks us off
very strongly at eight
and then over on the website i want to
say thank you to justin king who just
signed up at joinpackman.com
i am going to make an announcement right
now because this is actually so
important
uh
we hit a billion subs i'm sorry not a
billion subscribers
excuse me
we hit a billion views on youtube
yesterday
tomorrow i am going to be announcing via
email
a billion view membership special
the code is billions
billions is the code i'm telling you
right now because the code is active and
you can use it i'll show you how you
some people might not know how to spell
billions you just type it whoa i didn't
spell it right you type in billions and
your six dollar membership goes to a
dollar eighty okay take advantage of
this now it even works on yearly as you
can see here if i switch to yearly
and type in billions
60 a year becomes just 18
everybody will get a thank you
and it might get us into stream number
two today which will just be basically a
double length
stream which is just amazing
all right so we've got that going on
let me do super chats i have so much to
catch up on though so so i'm gonna run
through these
congrats on a billion don't spend this
all in one place
david it's so cool you had a show at
wxoj i also had a show in the creepy
dusty old
basement of the old board of ed building
yes
daniel says if the stream is wide and
long enough it may have to be
redesignated a river
nicely done daniel
phil says how was spain david i happened
to be in acarunia at the same time did
you get a chance to listen to rm baba
brown yesterday
no i don't know what rm baba brown is
but spain was tremendous
really great
tyler says here supporting the show love
you david thanks tyler i really
appreciate that david sir my wife and i
are getting weird yellow cucumbers as
well they're great lemon cucumbers
pedro says i'm having jaw surgery
thursday send thoughts yes pedro has
been around for a while
uh
best of luck best of luck and uh wishes
for a
the best possible recovery pedro
appreciate your support over the years
brett says sir thoughts on recent
sanctions involving russian ammo ban is
it an appropriate response to the
navalny poisoning i have not yet i don't
know enough about it yet to take a
position
friendly reminder that your most popular
youtube video has recently surpassed 10
million views yeah not only did we hit a
billion views overall
as you can see here
we also had our first single video
surpass um 10 million views which is
incredible
incredible accomplishment
what of vaccine resistant covet variants
yeah over time as as the uh as what's
out there drifts from the alpha variant
we would expect the vaccines to become
less effective that's why eventually the
vaccine will be tailored
to the variants
do you think the us is technically at
civil war already i do not
i do not
i want to say a big thank you to seamus
mcginnis who is the first person in the
history of the show to get a membership
on my website with the coupon code
billions also welcome to kade smith kade
just signed up with the code billions
putting us at 11.
also big thank you to benjamin jabe
tubbs
infectious 101
thanks for the twitch subs putting us at
13. if you're just joining us we have um
reached an incredible accomplishment one
billion youtube views one billion that's
nine zeros
and to celebrate
we are using the code billions at
joinpackman.com
for an incredible discount
kyoko who has called in from japan
before hey kyoko kyoko says hi david i'm
up at 3 30 a.m to congratulate you for
one billion views
congratulations love your show thank you
kyoko i appreciate that
very much appreciate that all right let
me get into
a few different um
things here
here is a video that was made by
one of our one of our regular viewers i
don't did small fuzzy moss do this one i
don't remember but this is a nice one
check it out supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous uh whether it's
ultraviolet or just very powerful light
and i think you said
that hasn't been checked but you're
going to test it right and then i said
supposing you brought the light inside
the body you can which you can do either
through the surface sure uh in some
other way
sounds interesting
right and then i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out
in a minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that oh yeah
[Applause]
so that's that's trump with a laugh
track which is pretty clever
here is a great interview these are
interviews of trump supporters
talking about how much they care about
the people in afghanistan and then
they're asked so we should take them in
as refugees right and they say well no
that that'd be crazy so afghanistan
total mess yeah um he you know biden
pulls out of there and really you know
screws up and you know leaves high and
dry the citizens of afghanistan yeah
that was it's atrocious women and
children they lose
not to mention a lot of people don't
talk about what they do to boys in those
countries it's absolutely atrocious and
so do you think we should take them in
as refugees no no no simply put no you
know the kids the you know the women
children
you know these people are not it's
terrible it's open right now it's
terrible for them
so you don't you don't think we should
take in any refugees from afghanistan no
i well you know that
there's people that helped us there
um
but
they helped us but they're bad so we
shouldn't take them in
and no our country should not be open to
anybody right now no they shouldn't take
in any refugees right now they should
just have the same policy that they got
on the canadian border that stretches
from seattle all the way to newfoundland
no one gets across that border right now
at all
why are we taking in a bunch of these
people that are just going to be a bunch
of democratic voters it shouldn't be
open to anybody we're too bad right you
can't just have people busting over our
borders this is biden's mistake if
anybody should take anybody in for
refugees it should be biden so all the
refugees should go to delaware
[Music]
it's a joke that i had but but
definitely no
biden's afghanistan mess
i think this woman ends up crying but
then still says no refugees let me see
he just sort of left people high and dry
with that women the children the you
know families
[Music]
it's what do you think
[Music]
yeah
there's really no words
[Music]
it's awful it's awful and it's um
you know
we did that as america we were in for
the first time in my life
it just it's heartbreaking
you know it's just not who we are it's
not who we are and uh
yeah that's that
yeah thank you thank you
and so i mean
should we should we take them in as
refugees
i think there's a whole lot of things
that i don't fully understand about that
and i think there's a whole lot of
things that need to be fixed before we
consider that yeah not now look at the
crying ends instantly no more crying all
of a sudden
i would need to be educated but probably
you know as heartbreaking as that is to
say we we shouldn't um i think there are
we need to be cautious right
she was just crying about the people
that she now doesn't want to help so
yeah so like let's let's hold off on
that for now let's hold off on that for
now yeah
which is hard yeah but yeah let's hold
off on that for now
these people have no idea what's going
on you guys all know that obviously um
but that is uh it's like someone turned
off someone turned off the switch on
crying they just said boop off no more
crying that's it
uh all right let's do a few more super
chats here sir can you address the
frequent 2 a.m view dumps it's actually
3 a.m so 3 a.m eastern midnight pacific
that's when youtube tallies views from
the last 24 hours and that's why they
update at that time each day nothing
suspicious
john says if joe biden decides not to
run for re-election which is very likely
who do you think kamala will pick for
her vp i say gavin newsom not even
thinking about that yet
no idea
legionary dragon says heard of ac12
variant from south africa sounds like it
is antibody resistant
antibody resistant
only two percent of total infections but
i believe it's been labeled a variant of
concern i thought it was a variant of
interest i didn't know it was one of
concern yet
kade says billions glad to support yeah
there's actually a bunch of other people
dumping in billions memberships hold on
let's see here
um
got a bunch of these
po hold on is that home paul horn has
just signed up with a coupon code
billions
michael serrano has signed up with a
coupon code billions nathan kreitman is
a new member with the code billions
michael schuster has just signed up big
massive dumps john mcmichael is a new
member with the coupon code billions
so is abraham grimaldo want to say
thanks to kobe
lukasic for signing up also richard or
kieza dumps
uh and then lastly barbara
nakakihara nakakihara i believe is the
pronunciation that puts us at 20.
remember we will continue after the
biden event into the sake event if we
get to 100 twitch also counts over on
twitch i want to say thank you to texas
bear claw for the resub
jen here just gifted five
and technicolored also re-upped the
twitch sub putting us at 27 and then
remember that patreon counts as two
if you go to patreon.com david pakman
show
and make a pledge that'll actually
bump us by two which is great
which is really great
all right a couple of other things that
i want to catch everybody up on a lot of
material here this was spotted by one of
our viewers there's a pour over
system for sale on amazon
and the uh viewer image
is using a david pakman show mug look at
that
pour me more pour over this is new from
about a week ago
using the black david pakman show mug
this little ceramic pour over is simple
to use in good quality it came with a
pack of cone filters so i was all set
fits over my coffee mugs but you should
check that it rests safely on your mug
before using it so you don't have an
accident and try to sue yourself like
the mcdonald's lady scalding herself
with coffee went after i assume it says
mcdonald's so that's cool somebody uh
using their
a pacman mug
which is great
uh still standing by here for joe biden
thanks to morder stroller for gifting
five subscriptions on twitch putting us
at 32
also whoa hold on a
second this is crazy they call them
dumps memberships are flying in samantha
gao just signed up with the code
billions
sue sinclair is a new member
nathan quimby is a new member it wasn't
nathan quimby the name of the mayor in
the simpsons anybody remember
i know it's mayor quimby was it nathan
quimby
nobody's heard of the simpsons okay also
thanks to maria scarmea
for signing up with the coupon code
billions and joe edge has also signed up
putting us at 37
if you don't know it was joe quimby if
you don't know why we have the code
billions it's very very simple
overnight last night in the uh
in the depths of night
our youtube channel hit a billion views
a billion views and not only that by the
way
we also
have surpassed 10 000 subscribers on the
the second youtube channel which has
content from the streams
we are at 10
200 there now as well
so a lot of the numbers going in the
right direction needless to say
thank you also to tazani for subscribing
via twitch appreciate that all right a
few other super chats then let me get to
some voicemails from the standpoint of
views congratulations
sir appreciate that
kristen says greetings from switzerland
my husband dominique and i listen to you
as we fall asleep i don't know if that's
a compliment or an insult but i
appreciate it either way
david sir which of your harvest is far
and above grocery store produce also try
pickling your eggplant outstanding i
have to tell you the eggplants are more
more flavorful than the ones i get at
the grocery store the tomatoes are more
flavorful
um
i guess that's it i mean the cukes are
okay so far but you don't really find
lemon cukes at the grocery store so it's
hard for me to say
you know better worse these are
metaphysical questions
more than anything else
do people want to take a look at
a new trump interview with stuart warney
or do you want to listen to a few
voicemails we haven't done voicemails
for a while and i've got hundreds and
hundreds of voicemails what do people
prefer
um
people prefer
more discussion of my vegetables okay
well i can do that i mean i've never run
out of things to say
let you know that's a good idea let's do
voicemails we're going to have a gap
between if we get if we're lucky enough
or unlucky enough to get to the second
stream today we're going to have a gap
between biden and sake so let's maybe do
some voicemails and leave the interview
for the gap
um
let's take a look here
let's see what we've got
as far as interviews as far as
voicemails go
uh
366 of them wow
that's a lot
let's just jump right in here
sorry just pulling everything up
um
well where are my voicemails i can't
even find them now
ah here we go
okay here we go
hey david b-dog here uh my question
today is this
if donald trump runs for president in
2024
do you think he will become the third
presidential candidate to lose the
popular vote
three times
i'll take my answer off the air pac-dog
i do not know the answer to that that
would that's a really interesting
question it's one we're gonna have to
wait on as far as an answer is concerned
so um i'm kind of getting a little bit
more curious about this afghan war and
exactly like what
the motives inside we're going to skip
over that woman's voicemails for the
most part because they are insufferable
so i don't mean to say this from
threatening um
[Music]
but i do think that um there's like a
really good
uh outlook on
like um
how we put this correctly like um
like with the jewish people yeah the
outlook for the jewish people is very
good
hey mr pakman um you know i just saw the
august 30th show where you are talking
about
uh counter arguments to religious
excuses for
not um
not getting vaccinated
and this whole thing about an afterlife
and about
religious consistency
here's another there's another way to
point out the self-contradiction that
these so-called religious people who
believe in afterlife in heaven
there's another one to throw at him okay
if committing suicide by russian
roulette
which means that the trigger pool the
first trigger all right we're gonna move
on from that i did forget i have one
other thing to show you guys this is
really funny i got this email
from a viewer named taggart who wrote to
me about earthbread and said mr packman
sir my la my name is misspelt mr pacman
sir sir you can't ask that question my
girlfriend and i very powerfully
harvested our potatoes this morning they
grow underground not a lot of people
know that but they grow underground and
you have to dig them up with great
strength your blessing upon our potatoes
would mean the world to me and we would
offer you our thanks each time we roast
some for dinner your humble and loyal
supplicant tag art and look at these
look at these incredible potatoes
i absolutely bless the potatoes with
peace and love peace and love
i commend you for great strength and
massive dumps of produce taggart thank
you very very much i think that you're
doing important work there and they do
grow underground it's true that not a
lot of people know that and it does
require
great strength to dig them up
very true
i want to say thank you to gordon z hall
for re-upping their twitch prime
subscription
i actually don't even know if i should
be streaming because because of the
dearth of uh that's d-e-a-r-t-h because
of the dearth of streams we've dropped
down to what is an embarrassingly low
687 twitch subs
i probably should be dumping bots in to
raise that up before even streaming
because i think it could definitely
damage brand reputation right now
to even be streaming at 687 but alas we
are here and i want to say thanks to
chief boris as well for re-upping your
new member number 40. we have one stream
coming up which is this one
and then if we get to 100 i'm just going
to keep streaming into the gensake press
briefing it could be a record-setting
stream on that note guitar goddess has
just re-upped her sub putting us at 41
and jen here just gifted two more
putting us at 43. also over on the
website people are taking taking
advantage of the coupon code
um billions because we hit
a billion youtube views yesterday and i
want to make sure i thank everybody who
signs up there pam fong just signed up
with the coupon code billiam's billions
thanks pam tyler gettys just signed up
with the code billions daniel gamino is
using the code
cecilia destino
which means destiny has just signed up
on the website and ross garcia is the
newest member with the oh sorry there's
a few more here
saxon hampton is a new member with the
code billions so is robin grewal
and lastly anthony webb thanks to all of
you putting us at 51 already
lastly welcome to pink and blonde who
has re-upped their twitch sub
23 month subscribed on twitch that is
incredible
that is absolutely incredible
um what a day
what a day
and if people would prefer to use an
earlier coupon code like my hipaa it's
still valid you can still sign up with
the code myhippa you've just got to know
how to spell it oh wait it's right up
there
it's yeah okay so that's how you spell
it
that's how you spell it
also thanks to the brodels for signing
up via twitch putting us at 53. very
much appreciate that let's do a few
other super chats and then we'll get
back to voicemails
um
[Music]
sir i see a reflection in the screen
behind you i apologize for that
mayor joseph fitzgerald o'malley
fitzpatrick o'donnell the edge quimby
nicknamed diamond joe is the mayor from
the simpsons okay i didn't know that
jimmy from philly says trump won hey
guys we are gonna have a very special
stream tomorrow
okay
uh we are going to be doing a live
stream
with violent
criminal trumpist jimmy from philly
and dr alok kenosha of healthy gamer
fame
who is a psychiatrist i am basically
going to be
explaining to dr k the genesis of jimmy
from philly as a personality um
of a violent trumpet personality we're
going to talk about jimmy from philly's
run-ins with the police and his
alcoholism and smoking and everything
and then dr k is hopefully going to help
us get to sort of the root of how jimmy
became the way jimmy became
is it trauma induced is it what is it
what is it so that's tomorrow 1 p.m east
noon central 11 mountain
10 eastern
okay that's tomorrow assuming everything
goes well now i am scared about one
thing which is we are using discord to
line it all up jimmy in the past has
very loudly complained he doesn't know
how to use discord and the dr k team
is sort of trying to walk jimmy through
all of it
um so hopefully it happens i'm worried
that there could be a technical element
that interferes
but needless to say
scheduled for tomorrow is a sort of
intervention as it may be
involving jimmy from philly and dr k and
i will i'll sort of be helping it'll
almost be like couples therapy in a
sense i'm gonna be there and it'll be
recorded it'll be put online every you
know if i see people saying they're
working and all this different stuff
it's gonna be fine okay
it's gonna be fine
so that'll be um
that'll be tomorrow
uh
someone's saying
mike from pa says you're a mossad plant
that's that's very anti-semitic
if that's true that's extremely
anti-semitic
i thought it was mike from jersey
wait jimmy now i'm confused jimmy from
philly no it's jimmy from philly
i thought it was mike from jersey
mike from pa huh
i don't even know
all right well anyway that's tomorrow
jimmy from philly with me and with dr k
i do want to say thank you to a bunch of
people who just resubbed and subbed via
twitch prime bobby dune real time fans
sir rock legubrius martin o'muse and
savvy lemons
that is six putting us at 59.
over on the website i want to say thanks
to quincy suthers who just signed up
with the coupon code billions riley
putnam just signed up with the coupon
code billions joshua ojeda signed up
with the coupon code myhippa
charles mustaglem just signed up with
the code billions and noah camacho is
our newest member putting us at 64.
the deal i made with people is
we get to a hundred
after this stream there's really no
after i just keep going into the saki
press briefing which is scheduled for
right after joe biden
addresses the nation
so that's upcoming if people want it
david sir next time you're in europe
please come to amsterdam then i'll take
you to our ajax football club love your
show i would love to get back to
amsterdam
amsterdam's great
stephen lopez says david do you know
what's happening in puerto rico today 28
people died of covid six were vaccinated
i admit i have not been following what's
going on in puerto rico
but i will uh i intend to
and our friend jamal swift is back
saying hey homie this is the top super
chat today
hey homie it's been a while hope you're
good where can i view that funny video
of the guy interviewing trumpies about
afghanistan refugees i believe adam
parkamenko tweeted it out
adam parkamenko
so check that out
let's do a few more voicemails
so i have like an interesting story all
right we're basically going to skip
those
so what i think would be like suitable
as far as
um like another goes all right we're
mostly skipping those
so i was just doing some research at
least she's calling me sir that's polite
i'm really curious as far as um
intelligence or women like her me too me
too
but um as far as like um when you're
getting older all right and continuing
but i feel as far as like kind of like
going above and beyond the call of duty
when it comes to politeness like all
right so it just keeps going and going
we'll go to someone else now oh my god
that first question that kevin guy
is this a asmr bernie guy
he's one of those younger
viewers callers
who i think really need to find
themselves
before they go interacting with others
in the media
he sounds too tentative he doesn't sound
clear on what his question or his
comments are
and looking at the way he was staring
straight into the camera i found that
equally scary
yeah there was a call last week where i
was sort of trying to figure out what
was going on and i was just uh
uh staring staring right into the camera
that's true
third call and one night anyway the
reason i'm calling for the third one is
i think we've got something like seven
billion or nine billion people on planet
earth
and at the seven billion rate
if you uh all right okay we can't deal
with that right now
i was just looking through my reading
list and it was like recommendations for
you
and it's like
why are all the black girls sitting in
the cafeteria and i'm out on that note
gonna get away from that let's listen to
some others
hi david um you know lately in the news
we've been seeing
you know an immense amount of coverage
over afghanistan um which i understand
because it is obviously a major story
um but i am wondering if
one of the things that maybe people
aren't taking into account um
in regards to biden's motives is the
fact that um if you look at his
his age
um i i wonder if vietnam the vietnam war
kind of weighs on him um okay all right
very speculative i can definitely look
into that hey i'm just realizing i i
thought of this because of these um
europe-related super chats like sean
said david if you go to answer to
amsterdam don't accidentally do meth
um i don't think i told the story on the
bonus show but because the bonus show is
so under the radar you know because it's
it's restricted to our to our members
um
i was recognized
in frankfurt i was in frankfurt for like
20 hours
i went out to eat twice and once i was
recognized by a viewer who maybe is
watching right now i'll tell you guys
the story i was in in frankfurt
and i just had a layover there i went to
this place for dinner called naive
great great place
nice beer garden i sat outside i was
told you know sir if you're going to sit
inside you've got to be a show proof of
vaccination and all this different stuff
which i was glad to do but it was such a
nice day i sat outside they had these
big beer garden tables which could
probably accommodate 10 people but
because of the pandemic the way they had
it set up was one couple sits on one
side and one couple sits all the way on
the other side so my girlfriend and i
are sitting there
two people come in
and a guy says to me in german even
though i don't speak german because of
how he was gesturing towards the table
he was clearly asking me are these seats
taken and i said i don't speak german
but the seats are not taken it was a
beautiful cross-cultural moment of peace
and love and then they sat down and they
were there and then i was there with my
girlfriend
and then it starts to rain because the
weather changed meteorologically
um and oh hold on hold on i have a drop
for that actually
um
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of water yeah it started
raining so the people on the end get up
and the guy comes over to me and he says
excuse me are you david pakman and i
said yes i am and he said you know when
when i sat down when you said you didn't
speak german i started thinking
this could be david pakman i watch you i
watch the streams his name was thomas
and so if thomas is watching it was
great to meet you in frankfurt it was an
incredible
uh coincidence i guess we would call it
i don't know
so uh that was that was very cool very
very cool and this isn't an advertiser
this place is very cool naive
naive in frankfurt
uh monday is pizza night i was there on
a monday a couple mondays ago
and i can highly recommend
different
elements of pizza
so that was cool
um all right let me say a few other
thank yous we are we are working towards
a second stream today
i want to say thank you to
shaktipata
person person the weebs and cactus mat
for the twitch prime subs putting us at
68.
the next person would be number 69
um so that's all happening if we get to
100 we'll do a second stream
other super chats coming in 420 dragon
says i have a mental illness without you
over the past two years i wouldn't have
made it thank you so much i'm so glad i
was able to help
um not medical advice make sure you are
receiving proper care talk to a medical
professional in the case of any kind of
emergency
unknown geek says free jimmy from philly
interview title idea what's the dealie
with jimmy from feely hmm i don't know
about that
web surfer says david sir it's
pronounced iax
not ajax
okay
and very stable geniuses usa is not a
democracy stop expecting normality it's
a land of sheep and dogs stop trying to
be fair
peace
says very stable genius
thank you
thank you i appreciate that
let's listen to a few more voicemails
hey david big fan of the show um just
wanted to call in and let you know that
um i don't believe you're gay um i
believe you're a straight man
and i just want to thank you for coming
out as straight um it takes a lot of
personal uh hardship
i know a lot of people go through a lot
coming out of straight but you didn't
seem to have gone through a whole lot
going out of straight yeah it was
surprisingly easy for me to come out as
straight the caller is right so i just
want to thank you from the straight
white community yeah i'm not white
though that's that's the only thing
hey david um i'm a big twitter user and
i noticed you haven't been that active
on twitter yeah i was on vacation okay
very good
so um i think one thing i noticed here
in america is that some of the jewish
people are kind of like losing their
faith
and yeah jews are very non-religious
that's actually an accurate observation
um let's listen to a couple
other things hey dave i don't uh
appreciate how you keep
troy york now oh
uh the date has passed that people said
trump would be released
i think you only concentrate more on
your man joe biden he looks very unique
he almost lost it i think he was close
when peter duchy was given a hard time
peter duchy did do something then troy
york called right back
attacking joe biden is a clear criminal
and the government is
under the control of the psychopath
delta airlines and other businesses are
being extended by the buildings what is
what is troy york even talking about
okay mr pacman i heard that you're going
to bring vincent roccanello from quote
unquote this weekend virology yes he
will be on with me thursday
aka professor year
uh onto your show
all right that's very interesting okay
uh raccanello is a very useful
virologist egghead
but his huge and glaring weakness is
that he is not a clinician
okay no he's a virologist you know the
it's like no matter who you bring on
there's some complaint it's like i bring
on
uh i bring on a pulmonologist who treats
covered pneumonia and people say
that's not an epidemiologist he really
can't comment about you know the shape
of the of the of the pandemic
and it's also not a public health okay
right yeah but it's someone treating
covent pneumonia okay
now by popular demand we're bringing on
vincent racanello who's a virologist and
this guy's like well that's not a
clinician yeah i know
okay so what like what's the problem
dear god
okay
continuing on on cyrus kobe 2 and corona
virus link there are or covered 19. okay
i'm kind of getting annoyed with this
guy
we need to throw every weapon
and every mitigation all right this is
every this is every few minutes he's
calling in
never forget david
that the virus can't do anything
by itself
without a host okay
um very good casey says david i'm trying
to extend my support to the
480 a year plan that's what we call the
big boy here at the show
that's when you do no coupon codes you
go to yearly and you just go boom
okay
um but the codes aren't working it reads
please fix the errors above
well one thing is if you're trying to
pay 480
you don't add a code
you don't i mean because then it'll be
less i don't know
um
maybe send us send me a screenshot
you can you can write in for support at
uh info davidpakman.com
all right a few other people to thank
via twitch
zero cool has gifted three subs
ky dizzle has resubbed
bowflex man
has also signed up putting us at 73.
we're getting very close to a hundred
guys in which case we will do a double
length podcast and continue after biden
into the gensake briefing we also
because last night early this morning we
reached a billion views that's one
billion that's one with a b and nine
zeros
no one with nine zeros and then a b yeah
uh we have a coupon code
billions on the website you can sign up
on my website with the coupon code
billions if you apply it to
oh i don't know the six dollar a month
membership
billions
it drops your price to 180 okay
it is a perfect day to take advantage of
that at joinpacman.com i want to thank a
few people who did
including eddie t
hold on eddie t has signed up
um matthew fogelsong is a new member
john anderson is a new member carlos
brezzini has signed up as well as jay
allen pooley putting us at 78. we're
getting there
it's illegal it's legal yeah yeah it's
legal it's legal
why is money used as an argument against
battling climate change and other
progressive ideas money is fake just a
human concept climate change is real we
have the resources but we don't have the
time
very well said maddie
what good is money if there's no planet
oh people are asking for band bana unban
requests i don't think i have any
let me see here
oh i do hold on a second
let's hold on let me grab my mallet
i didn't think i had any unban requests
but let's see
uh if you get banned on twitch you can
request being unbanned
we will start with a user named
bald tacos
who says what's up you commies can't
even get a thousand liberals on stream
there's hope for the world
they were banned
their unbanned request is every single
one of you libtards will rot in hell
glad to see your channel is dead
our channel's actually having the best
year we've ever had that is a denial and
perma
very very easy
here is another user who was previously
banned their username is saibot lele
they came in and said
obama throws race cards because blacks
has higher death rate pathetic
they then came in and said trump 2020
trump 2020 trump 2020 trump 2020 trump
2020 on and on and on in all caps
they were banned
they came back and said hey i'm sorry
for spamming i just wanted to chat
rolling with some debates not gonna do
it again
oh i don't know
i mean they're apologizing but it's so
stupid
yeah i think that that's a perma-ban
this court has made that
permanent
sorry it's it's a little too stupid
not going to be able to uh
not going to be able to bring you back
here okay
thank you very much
palm beach county enacted mass mandates
for schools cases here up to 164 000 all
hospitals maxed out
yes it's crazy what's going on in
florida
congrats now you're the david pakman
show with nine zeros exactly
skeptic says what are your thoughts on
deficit hawks i think they're mostly
hypocrites
that's basically it
let's keep going with voicemails and see
what else we've got
finally oh sorry just thought of this
david uh i'm gonna invoke the whole nazi
thing too
okay
show me a nazi collaborator during world
war ii
who wasn't proud of being a nazi
collaborator
i'm bored by it i'm just i i just don't
like it very very bored by this person
let's see what else we've got
uh oh
i think i may have just lost my
connection to
the voicemail
let's see if i can um
refresh here
okay here we go
congratulations sir you just won a
billion views
also david sir i used the coupon code
better 21 sign up for your show would it
renew next year will it still cost me 21
yes that's a really important question
this is not you know all those scams
where you've got the low low
introductory rate of two bucks
renewing at full price you know
everybody does this comcast
verizon
sirius satellite radio
everybody everybody does it
membership discounts on my website are
permanent
the price never goes up
never go it's just it's a permanent
discount it will always renew at the
discounted rate alright
let's listen to a few other voicemails
here
um gotta get back down to where we were
where was i
oh here we go all right
hi david this is franklin from uh
michigan again kansas survivors i was
watching about uh the developments
i was wondering if you and farron could
discuss the legal aspect
of the lawsuits against trump about
that'd be for a lawyer that would be a
lawyer would have to um a lawyer would
have to address that
um let's see what else we've got here
couple others
hello david this is jim from california
um just want to say love your show been
watching you for some time
um i enjoy everything you do thank you i
notice you've you've covered uh the the
california governor recall a few times
yeah um something i've been trying to
figure out i'm from california and um i
have not been able to get an answer to
this question maybe you can and let the
rest of us know
uh is it possible for those of us who
want to vote against the recall to
answer on the second question
is it possible to write in gavin newsom
i don't know the answer to that i know
that so the recall is basically two
parts it's do you want to recall newsome
if no wins that's it you don't they
don't even count the votes on who do you
want
if yes wins then the second part is who
do you want to win i don't know if you
can say no
but still vote on the second part as if
you wanted a recall does anybody in the
chat
know the answer to that that's a very
good question
very very good question
no so so you're not eligible to vote on
the second question is that the way it
works
and i guess specifically can you write
in
new some they wouldn't even count
newsome oh that's interesting oh i see
so people are it seems like people are
saying
either way you can vote on who you would
want
but
you can't write in newsom i guess is
what people are saying
you can say no and vote for a candidate
it just can't be new some okay that's
important that's important
okay
all right i guess people don't know
um
you can vote on the second it seems the
consensus is you can vote on the second
question just not for gavin newsom okay
very good
uh people are saying destiny is raiding
us i don't see that i don't think that
that's going on what i do want to thank
is uh starlet violets as well as lord
lebrand lee leemw
matt's b97
and corundum mccooter and casey bates
for the twitch subs putting us at 83.
guys we may be getting there we may be
getting there to to a second stream
today over on the website
louis revell has just pledged via
patreon patreon counts twice today
patreon counts twice
also want to say thank you to michael
bouchane who just signed up on my
website with the code billions
thanks to anthony sir noack for signing
up
desiree dilorenzo is a new member
mikhail lopez hernandez has just signed
up richard scipione
and tibor varga putting us at 91 guys we
are close to guaranteeing the stream
will continue into the sake event
where joe biden is i have no idea
but after that we have jensaki coming up
with a press briefing let's check the
official biden schedule this was all
supposed to happen hours ago
got rescheduled let's see what we've got
no biden was still scheduled for a half
hour ago
and saki still scheduled for 15 minutes
from now
so we'll continue to watch that
we'll continue to watch that in the
meantime i do have other voicemails to
get to
so um one of the things like i noticed
about people just after
like awareness of the holocaust was
raised and that trump thought that nazis
are like all right
so um
i just like think you should always be
careful with span in the future
i thought that you have a close run in
and there's like a lot of people there
who think that i had a close run in the
only running i had was my girlfriend had
a false positive test in spain and so
until we got a negative pcr i was scared
i was going to be stuck in spain it's
not has nothing to do with spain it had
to do with the tests people and
nazis are just like the same
they had like this huge parade
and um
they had like half of their costumes
um
like a jewish
person who's in jail all right yeah
we're not doing jewish jail costumes
right now um
people are mentioning that there's like
a blackout on twitch tomorrow i don't
know a thing about it and we're
scheduled to do an intervention with
jimmy from philly with dr eloque kenosha
tomorrow so i am going to be streaming
tomorrow can anybody tell me what the
blackout is is related to
i can't block her calls because they're
from an unknown number and if i do a lot
of people call from unknown numbers so i
can't do that
hate raids what's a hate raid god i
don't know what is going on
it's a blackout against trolling
what
listen we've had this jimmy from philly
thing
scheduled with dr k for like two weeks
i just don't think i can do that yeah
wait i can't do that i'm sorry guys
let's continue with the voicemails
hi
um in regards to your recent show
concerning treatment of being vaccinated
this would work in a metro area
i think that maybe there should be um
one hospital for the unvaccinated and
then all the other medical facilities
for those who are vaccinated and uh that
way there's going to be room for those
with heart attacks or car accidents
and the overflow would be concentrated
in that one hospital right maybe that
would help
uh people who
do have an emergency yeah that's i mean
i don't know that there's any obvious
answer to that issue but it's a major
major problem it's a major major problem
uh david pakman you are totally wrong if
joe biden was president
during covid
you would have five million people dead
that he would not have closed the
borders he would have kept allowing oh
shut up troy i'm so bored with troy york
um
let's see what else we've got here
so i kind of like got into your
discussion once um it was like the only
time i was kind of like iffy like
maybe this lady like
and i like weren't seeing eye to eye or
understanding each other
um
she's like from africa okay drunk
chicago guy calling in
oh man it's like i think the show is
playing in the background and he's on
speaker really far from the phone let's
go back to the beginning of that
that's really really bad
so
it's okay
because i'll be fighting
but for
fellas guys
drunk chicago guy firing a shot across
the bow at troy york disgusting i can't
have my [ __ ] remote
i can't find my remote and i don't know
how to pause
so he couldn't find the remote i guess
to turn down the tv in order to re leave
the voicemail
um
here's more
what's up guys
and go from chicago
[ __ ] death
jesus christ this is pissing me off
trump can go
literally second death
hey by the so i see people saying i
should organize a fight between drunk
chicago guy and troy york can i tell you
something
i'm gonna be careful what i say but
listen to this
um
last week
i got a proposal
to do a boxing match
against some streamer i had never heard
of i'm not even gonna say who it is it
doesn't matter i'm not gonna say who
wanted to organize it but i got a real
proposal and there's a detail about this
proposal
that is the absolute funniest thing
i was invited to do a boxing match
against the streamer i don't know if
it's with headgear i don't know the
ouncage of the gloves i don't know
anything about it okay
i was invited to do this in vegas
and the promoter the sponsor
the pitch was think about think about
this the pitch was we would like david
and this other streamer who's
has a much smaller presence than i do
to do
a celebrity boxing match
in vegas
we will pay
to fly david out
as well as for david's accommodations
and make a donation to a charity of
david's choice
um
and
if getting paid would make a difference
we would consider paying david to
participate
what on earth like aside from the idea
that i would do a boxing match
why on earth would i do it for no money
it's it's just ridiculous
uh it's like i would only consider it i
would only consider it and i'm not even
considering it
the only way i can would consider it
would be
if the financial incentive was like wow
that's life-changing right i mean as
people know i
you know i have an extremely high
savings rate i i only spend like five
percent of my income
so
even for a modest amount of money why
would i put myself at risk of shots to
the head
and whatever else
if it's not materially changing my
financial situation like
we would consider paying david if it
made a difference
get the hell out of here i'm gonna go
and get punched in the head
for someone else to make money it's
absolutely nuts
um the training costs money and they
would that would cost them money good
for them
good for them
it's absolutely insane
um
would they would get me a ticket to
vegas yeah i know it's it's completely
nuts all right last voicemail from
drunka drunk chicago guy
what is this orange space orange thing
talking about
what are you [ __ ] talking about he's
[ __ ] not
he's not for me
i'm not drunk
so [ __ ]
i can't do this i can't do this anymore
all right so that's uh that's drunk
chicago guy
let's get updated on twitch subs and
memberships and get an updated number
locavera n neptune
starlit violets
oh wait no i already thanked some of
these people locavera and neptune has
have signed up via twitch and twitch
prime putting us at 93.
over on the website
i want to say thank you
to
yeah it's quite a stream
andrew storsween has signed up kelsey
starks is a new member hey kelsey robert
adams has signed up beverly lynch is a
new member
mike fisher and ryan trusso have signed
up
casey blake and simon scott are new
members
carol horton and eric michaela have
signed up
putting us at 103
for the day
these are website members at
joinpakman.com
using the coupon code billions to
celebrate the fact that we've gotten to
a billion views on youtube let's refresh
and see if it's changed no i think it
updates once a day
there it is one billion five hundred
thousand views
coupon code is billions we are standing
by for joe biden and then after that it
will be gensake
scheduled to do a press briefing so it's
a big day really really big day
and joe biden is already running really
late
um okay
few other super chats coming in
let's see where we are
thanks for being a voice of reason great
channel thank you
biden and congress need to extend
pandemic unemployment yesterday it's set
to expire after this weekend i don't
think it's going to happen
where do you want to see the usa in 10
years on big fan from norway keep up the
good work sorry for you all
i would like to see us closer to carbon
neutral
and um
uh
with reduced inequality and a higher
standard of living i mean you know all
the basic
socially democratic things
yan or jan says thank you for all you do
david do a compilation video of all the
funny calls these are rich that would be
tough to do
michael hansen from sweden says seems
like history is repeating itself in the
90s the taliban cleaned up afghanistan
started schools the world sheared on
then they got radicalized
not sure that i see it the exact same
way
important point for more powerful
english it's regarding or with regard to
not in regards to critical distinction
from the standpoint of grammar
um if that's true i want to correct that
you know the one i got recently was i
was saying i hope people will avail
themselves of this big membership
discount and a couple people say people
wrote in and called and said david it's
avail yourself of
no no no it's a veil of avail avail
yourself uh no i'm sorry
it's avail yourself too it's avail
yourself of is correct
that's
correct from the standpoint of accuracy
okay thank you and we're moving on
people know what i mean sir drunks love
your voicemail nobody's seen such great
drunk voicemails i know
sir don't go boxing but serious question
what will biden say greetings from
amsterdam my guess is joe biden is going
to be device decisive here very decisive
people are saying that it's starting
we're standing by
is it starting
let's make sure we're in hd here
i mean we're already very late
thanks to endies
for the twitch sub putting us at 104.
npr says any minute okay good
good parents in florida letting their
children go into grocery stores without
a mask
hey david here's a clip of a trumper who
still suggests taking ivermectin after
going to the hospital we'll look at that
later
let me audit that
i'm gonna check it for bamboo fibers and
everything
okay good
sir how sensible is it to criticize
biden for the smaller details of leaving
afghanistan what exactly can biden be
held accountable or praised for just
beyond giving the order to leave listen
joe biden is ending a 20-year war that's
great that's the big picture the big arc
of history is bush got us into a 20-year
war biden got us out of it there were
details that were not handled correctly
and we can address that we can deal with
that there's no doubt
but he got us out of a 20-year war
that's a good thing
period
it's a good thing
big thank you to ryan boyd for signing
up on my website with the coupon code
billions also thanks to kyle bowman for
signing up on my website putting us at
106 for the day
sir the grammar tip was regarding your
caller oh okay yeah i did i didn't i
didn't realize i didn't think i had said
that but i didn't want to be defensive
um your command of the english language
is reliably powerful thank you
all right here we go
let's go over here
last night in kabul
the united states ended
20 years of war in afghanistan and
that's good the longest war in american
history
we completed one of the biggest airlifts
in history
with more than 120 000 people evacuated
to safety
that number is more than double
what most experts thought were possible
no nation
no nation has ever done anything like it
in all of history
the only the united states
had the capacity and the will and
ability to do it and we did it today
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
for weeks
they risked their lives to get american
citizens
afghans who helped us
citizens of our allies and partners and
others on board planes and out of the
country
and they did it facing a crush of
enormous crowds seeking to leave the
country
and they did it
knowing isis-k terrorists sworn enemies
of the taliban
were lurking in the midst of those
crowds
and still
the women and men of the united states
military our diplomatic corps and
intelligence professionals did their job
and did it well
risking their lives
not for professional gains
but to serve others
not in a mission of war
but an admission of mercy
20 service members were wounded in the
service of this mission
13 heroes gave their lives
i was just at dover air force base
for the dignified transfer
we owe them and their families a debt of
gratitude we can never repay but we
should never ever ever forget
in april
i made a decision to end this war
as part of that decision
we set the date of august 31st for
american troops to withdraw
the assumption was that more than 300
000 afghan national security forces that
we had trained over the past two decades
and equipped
would be a strong advert
in their civil wars with the taliban
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate that's
right
but
i still instructed our national security
team to prepare for every eventuality
even that one
and that's what we did
so we were ready
when the afghan security forces after
two decades of fighting for their
country
and losing thousands of their own
did not hold on as long as anyone
expected
we're ready when they
and the people of afghanistan watch
their own government collapse
and the president flee
amid the corruption of malfeasance
handing over the country to their enemy
the taliban
and significantly increasing the risk to
u.s personnel
and our allies
as a result
to safely extract american citizens
before august 31st
as well as embassy personnel
allies and partners
and those afghans who had worked with us
and fought alongside of us for 20 years
i had authorized 6 000
troops american troops to kabul
to help secure the airport
as general mckenzie said
this is the way the mission was designed
it was designed to operate under severe
stress and attack
and that's what it did
since march
we reached out 19 times to americans
in afghanistan
with multiple warnings
and offers to help them leave
afghanistan all the way back as far as
march
after we started the evacuation 17 days
ago
we did initial outreach and analysis
and identified around 5 000 americans
who had decided earlier to stay in
afghanistan
but now wanted to leave
our operation allied rescue
ended up getting more than 5
500 americans out
we got out thousands of citizens and
diplomats
from those countries that went to
afghanistan with us to get bin laden
we got out locally employed staff from
the united states embassy and their
families totaling roughly 2
500 people we got thousands of afghan
translators and interpreters
and others who supported the united
states out as well
now we believe that about 100 to 200
americans remain in
afghanistan with some intention
to leave
most of those who remain
are dual citizens
long time residents
who had earlier decided to stay
because of their family roots in
afghanistan
the bottom line
90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
and for those remaining americans
there is no deadline
we remain committed to get them out if
they want to come out
secretary state blinken
is leading the continued diplomatic
efforts to ensure safe passage for any
american
afghan partner or foreign national
who wants to leave afghanistan
in fact just yesterday
the united nations security council
passed a resolution
that sent a clear message about the
international community expects the
taliban to deliver on moving forward
notably freedom of travel freedom to
leave
and together
we are joined by over 100 countries that
are determined to make sure that taliban
upholds those commitments
it will include ongoing efforts in
afghanistan to reopen the airport
as well as overland routes
allowing for continued departure
for those who want to leave
and deliver humanitarian assistance to
the people of afghanistan
the taliban has made public commitments
broadcast on television
and radio across afghanistan
unsafe passage for anyone wanting to
leave including those who worked
alongside americans
we don't take them by their word alone
but by their actions and we have
leverage to make sure those commitments
are met
let me be clear
leaving august the 31st
is not due to an arbitrary deadline
it was designed to save american lives
it's just time to go
my predecessor the former president
signed an agreement with the taliban
to remove u.s troops by may the first
just months after i was
inaugurated
it included no requirement that taliban
work out a cooperative governing
arrangement
with the afghan government
but it did authorize the release
of 5 000 prisoners last year
including some of the taliban's top war
commanders
among those
who just took control of afghanistan
and by the time i came to office
the taliban was in his strongest
military position
since 2001
controlling or contesting nearly half of
the country
the previous administration's agreement
said
that if we stuck to the may first
deadline that they had signed on to
leave by
the taliban wouldn't attack any american
forces
but if we stayed
all bets were off
so we're left with a simple decision
either follow through on the commitment
made by the last administration and
leave afghanistan
or say we weren't leaving and commit
another tens of thousands more troops
going back to war
that was the choice the real choice
between leaving or escalating
i was not going to extend this forever
war
and i was not extending a forever exit
mm-hmm the decision to end the military
lift operations pretty basic airport was
based on the unanimous recommendation
of my civilian and military advisors
the secretary of state the secretary of
defense
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and all the service chiefs
and the commanders in the field
their recommendation
was that the safest way to secure the
passage of the remaining americans and
others
out of the country
was not to continue with 6 000 troops on
the ground in harm's way in kabul
but rather to get them out through
non-military means
in the 17 days
that we operated in kabul
after the taliban seized power
we engaged in an around-the-clock effort
to provide every american
the opportunity to leave
our state department was working 24 7
contacting and talking
and in some cases walking
americans into the airport
again
more than 5
500 americans were airlifted out
and for those who remain
we will make arrangements to get them
out if they so choose
as for the afghans
we and our partners have airlifted
100 000 of them
no country in history has done more to
airlift out the residents of another
country than we have done
it will continue
to work to help more people leave the
country who are at risk
we're far from done
for now
i urge all americans
to join me in grateful prayer
for our troops and diplomats and
intelligence officers
who carried out this mission of mercy
in kabul
and a tremendous risk with such
unparalleled results
an airmen an airlift
that evacuated tens of thousands
to a network of volunteers and veterans
who helped identify as those needing an
evacuation
guide them to the airport
and provided them for their support
along the way
we're going to continue to need their
help
we need your help and i'm looking
forward to meeting with you
and to everyone
who is now offering or who will offer to
welcome afghan allies to their homes
around the world including in america
we thank you
i take responsibility for the decision
wow
now some say sounds just like trump
started mass evacuation sooner
and couldn't this have been done had
been done in a more orderly manner
i respectfully disagree
imagine
if we've begun evacuations in june or
july
bringing in thousands of american troops
and evacuating more than 120 000 people
in the middle of a civil war
there still would have been a rush to
the airport
a breakdown in confidence and control
the government
and it still would have been very
difficult and dangerous mission
the bottom line is
there is no evacuation evacuation
from the end of a war
that you can run without the kinds of
complexities
challenges threats we faced none
there are those who would say we should
have stayed indefinitely
for years on end some say that i ask why
don't we just keep doing what we were
doing just stay forever why do we have
to change anything
the fact is
everything had changed
my predecessor had made a deal with the
taliban
when i came into office we faced a
deadline may 1.
taliban onslaught was coming
we faced one of two choices
follow the agreement of the previous
administration
and extend it to have or extend
to have more time for people to get out
or send in thousands and more troops
and escalate the war
to those
asking for a third decade of war in
afghanistan i ask what is the vital
national interest
in my view we only have one
to make sure afghanistan can never be
used again to launch an attack on our
homeland
remember why we went to afghanistan in
the first place
a lot of people don't because we were
attacked by osama bin laden and al qaeda
on september 11
2001
and they were based in afghanistan
we delivered justice to bin laden on may
2 2011
over a decade ago
al qaeda was decimated
i respectfully suggest you ask yourself
this question
if we've been attacked on september 11
2001
from yemen
instead of afghanistan
would we have ever gone to war in
afghanistan
even though the taliban controlled
afghanistan in the year 2001
i believe the honest answer is no
that's because we had no vital interest
in afghanistan other than to prevent an
attack
on america's homeland and their friends
and that's true today
we succeeded in what we set out to do in
afghanistan over a decade ago
then we stayed for another decade
it was time to end this war
this is a new world
the terror threat has metastasized
across the world well beyond afghanistan
we face threats from al-shabaab in
somalia
al-qaeda affiliates in syria and the
arabian peninsula
and isis attempting to create a killer
fight in syria and iraq and establishing
affiliates across africa and asia
the fundamental obligation of a
president in my opinion
is to defend and protect america
not against threats of 2001 right but
against the threats of 2021 and tomorrow
that is the guiding principle behind my
decisions about afghanistan
i simply do not believe
that the safety and security of america
is enhanced by continuing to deploy
thousands of american troops
and spending billions of dollars a year
in afghanistan
but i also know
that the threat from terrorism continues
in this pernicious and evil nature
but it's changed
expanded to other countries
our strategy has to change too
we will maintain the fight against
terrorism afghanistan and other
countries
we just don't need to fight
a ground war to do it we have what's
called over the horizon capabilities
which means we can strike terrorists and
targets without american boots on the
ground or very few if needed
we've shown that capacity just the last
week
we struck isis k remotely
days after they murdered 13 of our
service members
and dozens of innocent afghans
and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
whoa as commander-in-chief
i firmly believe the best path to guard
our safety and our security lies in a
tough
unforgiving
targeted precise strategy
that goes after terror where it is the
day
not where it was two decades ago
that's what's in our national interest
and here's a critical thing to
understand
the world is changing
we're engaged in a serious competition
with china
we're dealing with the challenges on
multiple fronts with russia
we're confronted with cyber attacks
and nuclear proliferation
we have to shore up america's
competitive to meet these new challenges
in the competition for the 21st century
and we can do both
fight terrorism
and take on new threats that are here
now and will continue to be here in the
future
and there's nothing china or russia
would rather have
would want more
in this competition in the united states
to be bogged down another decade in
afghanistan true
as we turn the page
on the foreign policy
has guided our nation our nation the
last two decades
we've got to learn from our mistakes
to me there are two that are paramount
china first
we must set
missions with clear
achievable goals
not ones we'll never reach
and second
we must stay clearly focused on the
fundamental national security interest
of the united states of america
oh man
this decision about afghanistan
is not just about afghanistan
it's about ending an era
of major military operations right to
remake other countries exactly
we saw a mission
of counterterrorism in afghanistan
getting the terrorists and stopping
attacks
morph into a counter insurgency
nation-building
trying to create a democratic cohesive
in united afghanistan something that has
never been done over many centuries of
afghan's
history moving on from that mindset
and those kind of large-scale troop
deployments will make us stronger and
more effective and safer at home
and for anyone who gets the wrong idea
let me say clearly
to those who wish america harm
to those who engage in terrorism against
us or our allies know this
the united states will never rest
we will not forgive
will not forget whoa we'll hunt you down
to the ends of the earth and we will you
will pay the ultimate price
and let me be clear
we'll continue to support the afghan
people through diplomacy
international influence and humanitarian
aid we'll continue to push
for regional diplomacy engagement to
prevent violence and instability we'll
continue to speak out for the basic
rights of the afghan people especially
women and girls as we speak out for
women and girls all around the globe
and i've been clear
that human rights will be the center of
our foreign policy but the way to do
that is not through endless military
deployments
but through diplomacy economic tools and
rallying the rest of the world for
support
my fellow americans
the war in afghanistan is now over
i'm the fourth president
who has faced the issue
of whether and when to end this war
when i was running for president i made
a commitment to the american people that
i would end this war
today i've honored that commitment
it was time to be honest with the
american people again
we no longer had a clear purpose in an
open-ended mission in afghanistan
after 20 years of war in afghanistan i
refuse to send another generation of
america's sons and daughters
to fight a war
that should have ended long ago
after more than two trillion dollars
spent in afghanistan right
costs that researchers of brown
university estimated
would be over
300 million dollars a day for 20 years
in afghanistan for two decades
yes
the american people should hear this 300
million dollars a day for two decades
can you imagine you take the number of
one trillion as many say
that's still 150 million dollars a day
for two decades
and what have we lost as a consequence
in terms of opportunities i refuse to
continue to war that was no longer in
the service of the vital national
interests of our people
and most of all
after 800 000 americans
serving afghanistan i've traveled that
whole country brave and honorable
service
after 20
744 american servicemen and women
injured
and the loss of 2
461 american personnel including 13
lives
lost just this week
i refuse to open another decade of
warfare in afghanistan
we've been a nation too long at war
you're 20 years old today
you've never known an america at peace
so when i hear
that we could have should have
continued the so-called low-grade effort
in afghanistan at low risk to our
service members at low cost
i don't think enough people understand
how much we have asked of the one
percent of this country
who put that uniform on
willing to put their lives on the line
in defense of our nation
maybe it's because my deceased son beau
served in iraq for a full year before
that
well maybe it's because of what i've
seen over the years
as senator vice president and president
traveling these countries
a lot of our veterans and their families
have gone through hell
hmm deployment after deployment
months and years away from their
families
miss birthdays
anniversaries empty chairs of holidays
financial struggles
divorces
loss of limbs traumatic brain injury
post-traumatic stress
we see it in the struggles
many have when they come home
we see it in the strain on their
families and caregivers
we see in the strain of their families
when they're not there
we see it in the grief borne by their
survivors
a cost of war
they will carry with them
their whole lives
most tragically
we see in the shocking and stunning
statistic
that should give pause to anyone who
thinks
war can ever be low grade
low risk or low cost
18 veterans on average
who die by suicide every
single day in america
not in a far-off place
but right here in america
there's nothing low grade or low risk or
low cost about any war right
it's time to end the war in afghanistan
as we close 20 years of war and strife
and pain and sacrifice
it's time to look at the future
not the past
to future that's safer
to future that's more secure
to future that honors those who served
and all those who gave what president
lincoln called
their last full measure of devotion
i gave my word with all of my heart
i believe
this is the right decision
a wise decision
and the best decision for america
thank you
thank you and may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
[Music]
joe biden completely decisive completely
decisive this was the right decision
period this was the right decision
period saying he takes responsibility
for the fact that it was chaotic he
takes responsibility something we never
saw donald trump do
um
and uh
it was going to be a mess no matter what
but i have to tell you
uh i'm about as pleased with that as one
could be
he has ended the 20-year war and that's
a very very good thing
and now there are
things to figure out for sure
because we got to our 100
member goal we will be continuing the
stream directly into gen saki's press
briefing i assume many of the questions
will be nasty and they will be about
afghanistan
i'm going to step away briefly we will
keep we will keep it right here going to
refill my water have a little snack and
then expecting gensake in probably 20 to
30 minutes i have interviews to go over
i have your super chats your voicemails
ivermectin nonsense and much much more
i will be back before you even know what
happened
i guess
all right everybody we are back you
earned this you really deserve credit
for me being here because we got to 100
website members and twitch subscribers
we are going directly into a second
stream i was only going to stream
the biden afghanistan speech which was
very good
um and we are going to continue right on
with jen saki i have even more people to
thank
um bit 101
m braunov z log
ones comp anir ben bagachi
a hughes d
j ten way gilgame and stone trilla have
all signed up via twitch that's one two
three four five six
seven eight
nine
106 plus nine is 115
very much appreciate that
also want to say thank you to people who
have been supporting with the brand new
coupon code on my website billions
because we hit a billion view on youtube
views on youtube
um
rosaria de jesus has signed up on my
website
richard bandoni is a new member jose
padilla is a new member and gloria
azarian has signed up that puts us at
whoa 119.
there we go let's fix that
uh that was incorrect there okay let's
get right into a few different things
that i said we would um we would look at
after here is someone
saying stupid stuff hey y'all it's becky
sue here
doing an update for you on my video vlog
so sorry it's been a minute since my
life is she canadian sorry
running a dehumidifier i guess the
horse dewormer
because i had a positive coca diagnosis
and my cousin jets
friend
had a friend is this real or is this a
parody i can't it's probably a parody
right i had a friend
and that guy sold me some horse to
warmer
so i took it took about a cup and a half
which turns out was a cup and a half
more than i was supposed to take
seeing as i'm not an actual horse okay
yeah so this is a joke all right fine
i'm less interested in the satirical
stuff but okay
um
no it has to be a parody some people are
saying it's real
no it's obviously a parody okay all
right let's go next to
um
this is sydney powell she was
interviewed in australia it's a [ __ ]
show
we released a video about it a little
while ago but this is um this is the
full thing this is really tough to watch
let's take a look let me ask you a basic
question do facts matter yes they do
i hope we get to them one of these days
as to what really happened in our
election and all the people who are
responsible for it
[Music]
this is this is just wild
[Music]
how did you come to be involved in the
in the election effort to post the
election i wish i knew
it was like this huge
tsunami
hit tsunami i was in the area at the
time
i had
worked with mr giuliani for a few days
before on another matter
and
the next thing i know i'm smack in the
middle of it and people are pouring in
with offers of help and
wanting to investigate wanting to give
us affidavits wanting to tell what they
saw again with the affidavits pacific
areas
and lawyers all over the country
came to the rescue
in local areas and
and in washington did you already have a
relationship with president trump yes i
did have a relationship with president
trump i knew rudy giuliani i need
essentially everybody that was in the
middle of all of it um what was your
relationship with trump did he trust you
i believe he did trust me
based on what that's a mistake
um
i don't really know how to describe that
other than conversations that we had had
that for obvious reasons i can't discuss
and had you been much in the oval office
yes i'd been there a number of times
so the election is technically over
you're
in the oval office with the president
what did that feel like what was the
atmosphere at that time
i would say it was one of great concern
because most of us there knew something
very wrong had happened
it was obvious to me from the
mathematical and statistical
impossibilities that occurred the night
of our election
i already had some knowledge of the
ability of voting machines to be
tampered with
very very important stuff
[Laughter]
oh man
very secure election with great strength
all right let let's get a few simple
facts straight in how many states were
smartmatic machines and software used in
the 2020 election i don't even know the
exact numbers after all your involvement
well the focus was on the six key swing
states
places where voting had stopped being
counted
the night of the election but you were
making some um uh
big statements very dramatic critical
statements about smart matters
involvement was in the election
well i know that smartmatic and dominion
were essentially inextricably
intertwined and had done business
together for a long time let's leave the
history just in terms of the 2020
election what was smartmatic's
involvement
oh you'd have to go look at our
complaint against with
with respect to the four states that we
filed legal complaints in to get the
details of that a google search would
tell you let alone anything that
smartmatic themselves have said
subsequently that they were involved in
one single county in la
are you saying you're not aware of that
i'm saying i think their involvement's
probably a lot bigger than that but she
thinks
their machines were used in one county
you're aware of that
well their machines might have been used
one place but their software could very
well been used other places
you claimed on fox that smartmatic
shifted votes from trump to biden in
multiple battleground states that was
your argument wasn't it
that there was an algorithm run in the
machines via the software that shaved
votes
from
trump and gave those i read the votes
were waxed actually biden what actual
research or fact checking did you do at
the time to find out what smartmatic's
actual involvement in the election was
yeah
and al gore etham that sounds suspicious
to me for smartmatic
you've made an allegation against
smartmatic that they stole a
presidential election i think it's
incumbent on both of us to know what
smartmatics involvement was it seems
like a pretty foundational fact
i mean i'm confused right now about why
you're here
how did you get into my house sir ma'am
i'm sorry because you made a series of
very strong allegations against
smartmatic and against dominion
containing many errors of fact they
reportedly narrowed the smartmatic
machines do you accept the fact now that
the company that you accused of stealing
a national election only operated in one
county in la in california no one county
one state no i'm not prepared to accept
that fact
i think smartmatic's involvement was far
more significant than that do i think
they're trying to minimize their
involvement of course i do you said that
smartmatic owns dominion how do you
justify such a basic factual error
i'm going to stop the center for you
that's it that's wholly inappropriate
questions as to facts will not be
allowed only questions as to conjecture
speculation and character assassination
will be allowed
in the litigation that we're in but
we're not
even in the area of great dispute these
are simple facts of who the interviewer
is like i haven't even entered into the
area of things that are debatable
we're done
whoops uh-oh
is that her orthopedic pillow i'm sorry
these are facts when we're in litigation
against me personally
i i understand that
yes i understand that these are very
serious allegations
but these are also very basic
she eventually returns for the interview
isn't this the best
oh there's a dog now
i'm highly skeptical of how long this is
gonna last okay
i appreciate you coming back
yeah well i'm volunteering my time here
this is all vol that's a funny concept
cause like
you've let them into your house it's all
voluntary we know that doesn't change
like if any voluntary interview couldn't
be a serious interview then essentially
interviews wouldn't exist like they're
all voluntary and come here to be
accused of
anything rudy giuliani has had his
license suspended and is likely to lose
his law license because of the way he
misrepresented facts um in the cases he
was involved in do you anticipate that
you will meet the same end heavens no
and rudy giuliani shouldn't have met
that end either right
the standard that they held him to there
is absolutely preposterous rudy giuliani
misrepresented the facts and lied about
a whole series of details related to the
2020 election that's why he's lost his
license i disagree completely
lawyers get things wrong lawyers
occasionally misrepresent things is she
saying that rudy got things wrong and
misrepresented things like is she
admitting that the only thing i know
that rudy misstated was something about
whether a fraud case had been filed or
not we had filed fraud cases
amongst many other things that people
who were dead had voted they hadn't he
misrepresented the numbers of people who
had voted in michigan he claimed that
people were on the roll who were dead
all of those people
they all turned out to be legitimate
they've been cleaning off voter rolls
right and left they've been bleaching
them
they've taken tens of thousands of
people off voter rolls after the
election people
voted before the election
there's a lot of track covering going on
out there in the various states because
of what happened in this election and
they know they were wrong
so in the end it's you and rudy giuliani
against the system isn't it
i wouldn't
she's trying to think wait is that good
do i want to say yes it is or is it is
that not good there are a lot more
people involved than me and rudy
giuliani what do you have
in your case you have a bunch of dodgy
affidavits that don't add up you have um
a group of people with uh
dubious
credentials that's your characterization
that's all your characters so far you've
provided no evidence you might as well
be working for dominion and smart man
i'm just waiting for you to provide the
evidence yeah asking for evidence means
you're in league with the people she's
accusing obviously
you'll see it in court she reportedly
had uh a cheat sheet in her orthopedic
back pillow
thank you
thank you
okay
so that's that's that oh god saki's
going they're underway 12 urban search
and rescue teams are currently
operational in louisiana to support
state and local efforts the coast guard
has been doing overhead flights
including in grand isle to search for
anyone in need of assistance so far
urban rest search and rescue teams have
assisted over hundreds of survivors and
their work continues
we're also in regular contact which is a
huge priority for people in the region
with private electricity companies to
ensure they have the resources they need
as they work to restore power in
louisiana and mississippi where more
than 1.1 million customers remain
without electricity we've seen some
people in mississippi get electricity
back and we're hopeful we'll see
continued improvements there are more
than 25 thousand linemen from 32 states
in dc
in the region racing to restore power
and fema has staged nearly 250
generators in the region to support
impacted areas we're going to get more
generators to the area to get more power
to the emergency services that need it
the most we also want to make sure that
individuals in the impacted areas of
louis louisiana know they can apply for
federal assistance we would encourage
anyone in need of assistance to visit
disaster assistance.gov or call
1-800-621
fema as of this morning 48 shelters are
open in affected areas throughout the
gulf coast fema has staged more than 4.4
million meals 3.2 million liters of
water and more than 124 000 tarps in the
region and additional ambulance crews
have been transported to louisiana and
mississippi the department of
transportation also issued a regional
emergency declaration for states
including alabama arkansas louisiana
mississippi tennessee and texas
providing flexibility for transporting
fuel as well as essential items like
food water and power restoration
equipment to support emergency relief
efforts and today we have two additional
actions to announce to increase the
availability of gasoline and ease price
suppressors first the department will
extend and amend an emergency
declaration that offers temporary
flexibility to how many hours a truck
driver can drive this applies nationally
to goods that support the coven 19
response and will now include gasoline
and other types of fuel building
materials medical supplies and food
because the hurricane is hitting i'm
being told the other streams better
let's try this stream for now increase
availability at this critical time we
are continuing to assess and we'll
continue to provide you all updates why
don't you kick it off josh good to see
you good to see you thanks jen uh two
subjects first on afghanistan the
president said that any additional
evacuations all right we can't see the
reporters so we'll switch back over
thank you effective immediately which
will expand the supply of gasoline that
can be sold in these two states and
increase availability at this critical
time we are continuing to assess and
we'll continue to provide you all
updates why don't you kick it off josh
good to see you good to see you thanks
jen uh two subjects first on afghanistan
the president said that any additional
evacuations will go through diplomatic
channels and that the united states has
leverage over the taliban
can you tell us
what those channels look like and what
kind of leverage the united states has
absolutely well first i would say i
would point you to the remarks that the
secretary of state provided last night
but let me give you some highlights of
that
we have enormous leverage over the
taliban including access to the global
marketplace that's not a small uh it's
not not a small piece of leverage and in
order to gain access to the global
marketplace uh we're going to be
watching closely as will the global
community i would note that yesterday
the u.n security council also signed a
passed a resolution
that made clear to what the expectation
is in terms of safe travel and
evacuation or departure i should say of
individuals who want to leave
afghanistan and nearly half of the
countries in the world have also signed
on a state to a statement making clear
that is the expectation that's the
diplomatic side and the other diplomatic
components that our secretary of state
will be focused on include establishing
uh presence in doha which is already
underway which is a place where we will
be able to operate from diplomatically
so we can have
access with consular officers and
diplomats who can engage with american
citizens or others our afghan partners
who want to depart we're working to set
that up now
the other piece is engagement with the
taliban which will continue
through our ongoing channels that we
have uh with but engagement with the
taliban is bad per trumpus except when
trump did it in which case it was good
but here it's bad uh and in regional
airports and also ensuring that there is
overland travel that is possible which
means departing being able to leave
across borders and the president touched
on this in a statement on the airport
front the more specific piece we're
working on with the cutteries and the
turks who are
important partners here is getting the
civilian side of the airport up and
operational again so that we can use
that not just for uh for flights for
people to depart but also for
humanitarian assistance which we would
work through programs like the world
food food program and others to
distribute so there are a number of
channels this is a priority the
secretary of state will be leading
they'll continue to provide updates and
we're hoping to make progress in the
coming days
and secondly on the economy
about the expiration of the extended
unemployment benefits
we know that black unemployment in this
country is above eight percent it's
above seven percent in new york nevada
illinois california
with the exploration how do you ensure
that people in those places still get
the support they need you're right and
josh it's vitally important to look at
the fact that there are different
circumstances in different states so if
we just take a step back and look at the
national landscape on these benefits
in about half of all states 24 governors
have already made the decision to
eliminate pandemic unemployment benefits
that's a choice they have made in the
remaining 26 states unemployment levels
vary pretty widely from 3 percent to 7
percent and half of these remaining
states have unemployment rates that are
already less than five percent so there
are differing needs in different states
and governors are making different
decisions uh what we're trying to do and
and what we announced about two weeks
ago but obviously there was a lot of
news going on uh is our effort to put
new tools in place to help states that
choose to further extend pandemic
unemployment benefits because of those
needs because
they're states like those you have
mentioned or because they have higher
rates of unemployment among african
americans or other groups that need
additional assistance so the secretary
of treasury and the secretary of
department of labor sent a letter to
chairman wyden and chairman neal
underscoring and affirming that states
can use their allocations of the 350
billion of state and local fiscal so it
sounds like no federal
extension but states can use the money
they've gotten to do so if they want to
90 million dollars in career grants
available to support comprehensive
re-employment services for all americans
and 146 million dollars in re-employment
services and eligibility assessments and
the department of labor also sent a
letter uh just last week to states with
information about how to leverage
existing ui program infrastructure to
leverage to deliver ongoing support to
unemploying workers we have also been
engaging directly with states we've been
engaged now with about 30 states and
counting to talk about what their
specific needs are and how programs that
are available can be eligible to people
in their states so that's one reporter
first on ida thank you for that
information you still tracking that he
might go to the region at some point
he certainly is open to that uh what he
does not want to do is interrupt rescue
and uh and
recovery efforts which as many of you
may or may not know who have covered
hurricanes before
people leaving their homes and going to
evacuation centers that can increase in
the days ahead it isn't always just in
the day after
and certainly there are ongoing efforts
on the ground as i just noted so he's
open to that i don't have anything to
announce at this point in time obviously
the president of the united states going
to a region takes a lot of resources
on afghanistan um
is there any sense of if and how many
americans might have left
today
is there even a way to track that for
the us government at this point well i
will say we remain in touch through a
range of means of communication email
text whatsapp
that's something that we could certainly
do from here but also having a presence
in doha and diplomats in the region will
enable that to happen
locally or
close by as well i don't have an update
for you on the numbers um but
that's something the state department
would have the best assessment of um we
have asked and talked a little bit about
the president's
mood over the last few days or his
you know his sense of all of this a few
of us observed he seemed angry at the
beginning of the speech today
uh who's he mad at
i would say i'll
give you a different assessment of what
i saw which is that he gave a forceful
assessment laid out a forceful case to
the american people as to why it was
time to wind down a 20-year war
that has
led to the loss of thousands of lives
and in his view and i think he made a
firm case of this it's not in our
national security interest to be on the
ground anymore you know north korea
isn't it logical to be mad that you're
ending a 20-year war that had no end in
sight and no way to win and people are
like sir what are you doing trump would
have done it better i'd be mad
well uh we have uh left the door open
and obviously reached out to our
channels i don't have an update for you
in terms of uh any response to our offer
offer remains to meet anywhere anytime
without preconditions we're obviously
aware of the reports we've seen over the
last 24 hours and we're closely
coordinating with our allies and
partners on developments and assessing
closely
the president said in his remarks just a
short time ago that in april a deadline
was set for august 31st in fact in his
april remarks he set a deadline for
september 11th so what changed over
these last few months between the august
31st deadline and the september 11th
initial deadline was that 11 days
a new time frame agreed to by the
taliban or suggested by them or by this
administration or what's the discrepancy
there the military uh
gave their assessment that they needed
120 days to wind down our presence in
afghanistan so we abided by that
but in the april speech september 11th
was today
that's a different date jen
between april and now and he based bases
strategic decisions uh i mean tactical
decisions i should say on the advice of
the military and commanders on the
ground and the timeline they needed to
wind down our presence but jen that's 11
days earlier timeline though it was not
the taliban's timeline
so he moved up the timeline to august
31st we needed 120 days and we abided by
the advice of the military
seems like satire
does can you clarify whether the united
states has an agreement with the taliban
to allow
more americans and other afghans to
leave good question well i will say jeff
that it is our not just our expectation
but also the expectation of a hundred
countries around the world the u.n
security council and others that the
taliban will abide by what they
committed to last friday which is the
ability of people to leave afghanistan
should they choose to leave
there do need to be ongoing diplomatic
negotiations or discussions i should say
that's a part of what the secretary of
state and his team will be leading but i
would note that
the taliban conveyed that on friday a
leader of the taliban again more than
half of the countries in the world have
conveyed clearly what they expect and
the un security council signed a
resolution yesterday so those are the
diplomatic pieces that have moved
forward but this will be a top priority
in the days ahead the president was
critical today and has been critical of
president trump's former president
trump's deal with the taliban
given that i'm wondering if this
administration or this president gave
any consideration to not holding on to
former president trump's special envoy
to afghanistan who stayed on
look i think the the president wanted to
be clear about what he was left when he
took office and he laid that out very
clearly in his speech but just to
reiterate since you gave me a couple an
opportunity a couple of the points
when the president took office
there was a deadline that was just three
months away that included for may 1st
that included no requirement that the
taliban work out a cooperative governing
agreement with the afghan government it
did release 5000 prisoners last year
including some of the taliban's top war
commanders so the president was walking
into yeah but we're supposed to believe
if trump did it it would have been all
perfect
a war he has long felt we needed to
depart from he's he's felt that was long
overdue but that was the circumstance he
walked into and frankly there's a little
bit of selective memory loss from some
of the people who served in the last
administration about these circumstances
but my question was actually why why
hold on to the
the afghan envoy u.s envoy to
afghanistan who served under president
trump why did president biden hold on to
him
the president has made changes where he
saw fit and has not made changes where
he felt the person continue to be the
right person for the job that's not a
political decision
go ahead thanks jen uh so we heard from
the national security adviser jake
sullivan this morning good morning
america he's mentioned that 90
of those on the ground there in
afghanistan and a small number of remain
they have reached out uh they got out
you know as many people as as they could
um
is the administration essentially
placing blame on americans who could not
get to the airport in time
i think what the president stated
clearly and i know that jake sullivan
has stated clearly and our secretary of
state has stated clearly is that our
commitment remains uh there is not an
end to our commitment to american
citizens that i don't think is a great
question because if you believe like if
you just think biden's lying then okay
but according to biden for months
they've been telling people it's time to
get out it's time to get out and he's
not saying he's cutting them off you
can't force people to leave at the end
of the day uh and we think it's still
important for the american people here
in the united states to understand that
one on al-qaeda so we heard from the
president a few months ago saying that
one of the main reasons to
go into this war was to
get al-qaeda we have heard that osama
bin laden's security chief has
reportedly returned to afghanistan and
has been seen in public do you still
believe or does the administration
believe that al-qaeda is no longer a
threat to america and given the isis
attacks that we've seen in the last week
how confident is the administration that
afghanistan isn't already a safe haven
for terrorists well i think first there
is a very big difference between
terrorists ability to attack u.s troops
in kabul and to attack the homeland and
we have we do not assess that any
terrorist group on the ground has the
ability to attack the homeland in the
united states it is incumbent upon the
president the national security team to
prevent that from ever being the case
but there is a very big difference
between those two
um
i know that the
military obviously uh recommended to the
president or at least he said he they
recommended to the president that
uh it would be best to leave
keep that august 31st deadline but the
president himself you know in his
interview with abc news that
uh that if there's american citizens
left but we're gonna stay until we get
them all out uh
i think the president's understand or
explained his rationale for leaving a
hundred plus americans behind but can
you talk about uh why
he allowed his credibility on this issue
to sort of go out the door on making a
flat promise
this is like the worst of the corporate
media when it comes to these things like
we should just stay everywhere all the
time to get out out that's that's an
enduring commitment one that will not
change and one we're going to focus on
every single day
i would also note
that over the course of the last two
weeks we have seen a terrorist attack
that took the lives of 13 of our service
members and there was an asset and part
of our assessment always is going to be
the risks a risk assessment so i think
the question was do you leave 6 000
service members as there are
heightening threats heightening risks
every single day or do you work through
a diplomatic process and efforts to
ensure that we will have the ability to
get these american citizens out that's
the assessment we made i mean that
terror attacked you and and he made
clear that you weren't going to let
the terrorists sort of dictate the
timeline so and we didn't and we've
evacuated tens of thousands of people
since then
i guess can you
was it a mistake for the president to
have promised that we would remain until
everybody left the country we are going
to get every american citizen out that
has not changed one last one on
um you mentioned the leverage that we
might have and
how access
i almost feel like the controversy's not
even landing like i know don jr is
tweeting about it and ben shapiro's
saying it's all terrible and stuff but
it it just it's like he ended a 20-year
war guys chance for
afghanistan the country to access its
reserves or
sort of
avoid those sanctions will will the
central bank be sanctioned are they
going to have that ability as part of
this sort of
partnership that you've you've talked
about well it's going to be based on
what their behavior is and i think the
president clearly outlined that we're
going to be watching as the world will
uh what the taliban does that is
certainly allowing american citizens to
depart it's certainly allowing afghans
and our partners to depart it's also
how they operate as it relates to
treatment of women to human rights
there's a range of factors at play here
so i don't have anything to predict for
you obviously
there's a great deal of economic
leverage you referenced sanctions that
are already in place
that we have that the global community
has and we'll have to assess how things
happen over the course of the coming
days weeks and months go ahead
jackie um one question on the dignified
transfer and i want to get to
afghanistan some of the gold star
families have criticized the present
president's conduct at the dignified
transfer there was a
father of one marine who said that the
president appeared to be checking his
watch every time a black draped
transport case came out of the plane and
a sister of another marine said that it
felt like a fake and scripted apology um
was the president looking at his watch
and does he have a message to those
people does he have a watch
that they were offended
i would say his message to all of the
family members who were there those who
were not even in attendance is
that he is uh grateful to their uh this
is embarrassing guys
they made to the country that he knows
uh firsthand what it's like to lose a
child and the fact that no one can tell
you uh anything or say anything or
there's no words that are going to fill
that hole that is left by that uh he's
not going to speak to and i'm not going
to speak to the private conversations of
course they have the right
to convey whatever they would like but i
will tell you from spending a lot of
time with him over the past couple of
days that he was deeply impacted by
these family members who he met
just two days ago that he talks about
them frequently in meetings and and the
incredible service and sacrifice of
their son and daughters i that is not
going to change their suffering but uh i
wanted to convey that still
on the future age of the taliban that um
jake sullivan was talking about this
morning yeah he said um when it comes to
economic and development assistance
with the relationship with the taliban
it'll be about taliban actions
should we understand that to mean that
economic and development assistance
could could translate to taxpayer money
eventually going to the taliban at some
point i know it's different from the
humanitarian aid we've been talking
about the world food program and things
like that but these specific references
that sullivan made this morning
well i would i would go back to kind of
the earlier question on this there's an
enormous amount of money they have at
the federal in the federal reserve i
shouldn't say they the government of
afghanistan has in the federal reserve
which they don't have access to right
now that's actually their money that's
being held there
so that's one of the questions here
there are also sanctions that are in
place and a number of leaders
obviously that prevents them from doing
business in various parts of the world i
think that's really what jake sullivan
was referring to
to get back real quick to this leverage
this issue of leverage i understand the
u.s plans use that leverage for safe
passage but what specifically
does the u.s also want to see from the
taliban that they would use that
leverage to get you mentioned human
rights or women's rights
will the us use its leverage if for
example the
taliban doesn't allow girls to go to
school or appears to be violating basic
women's rights she can't answer that i
think the president said that in his
speech
so things like access to the global
marketplace would be contingent on
girls being able to go to school women
fundamental women i'm not here to
outline specific parameters for you but
what i can tell you broadly is that
human rights
women's rights are certainly it seems
like we're stupidly going back to
can we just like make everyone's values
match ours again can we just westernize
everybody and hold them up but isn't
that how we get into these messes in the
first place like i would love it but it
just it doesn't seem like it's going to
happen responsible for that assumption
is the president frustrated with his
team at all for having made that false
assumption we don't have the luxury of
being frustrated our focus right now is
on uh continuing to move forward on our
diplomatic efforts uh and continuing to
do everything we can to get our afghan
partners and american citizens out and
to get afghans who have fought by our
side uh safely there's this weird thing
where now all of a sudden after like not
really talking about afghanistan for 10
years
everybody's coming together and they're
like
maybe we should reinvade afghan maybe if
he's invaded should we should we go to
afghanistan maybe we should maybe that's
an idea like maybe we could fix this
problem by just invading again go ahead
thanks jen um the afghan interpreter who
helped rescue then senator joe biden
when he was stranded 13 years ago in
afghanistan is now in hiding he told the
wall street journal hello mr president
save me and my family don't forget me
what's your response to him and why is
he and other afghan allies like him
still in the country if the president
believes as he said today that the
mission was an extraordinary success
well i would say first our message to
him is thank you for fighting by our
side for the last 20 years thank you for
the role you played in
helping a number of my favorite people
out of a snowstorm and for all of the
work you did and our commitment is
enduring not just to american citizens
but to our afghan partners who have
fought by our side and our efforts and
our focus right now is as you heard
general mackenzie say and others say
over the last 24 hours is to the
diplomatic phase we will get you out we
will honor your service and we're
committed to doing exactly that
good thanks so much jen um just to build
on some of the things my colleagues were
saying
president but
americans who uh
were given multiple chances to leave
dating back several months
but things have you just noted changed
dramatically in the last few weeks my
question is how many of those families
said they wanted to stay in afghanistan
in the last few weeks two three weeks
and is it really fair to say for the
president to say that they didn't leave
when they had the chance as you just
mentioned no one expected the collapse
uh has happened and the president
himself for months was publicly saying
that the taliban would not be running
things
um and that this and also that this exit
would be safe and organized
well i i would say first that no one is
placing blame here i think it's
important for people to understand
though what the process has been and
well there are between 100 and 200
american citizens who have not yet
departed
we have also evacuated more than 5 500
american citizens and their family
members and 115 000 other people from
afghanistan so more than 120 000 people
made their way to the airport or
this is one of the worst press briefings
i've seen in years from the standpoint
of the questions the vast majority if
not everyone though the state department
would have to speak to this who is still
there are dual citizens who have lived
their entire lives in afghanistan this
is about i know this is hard for people
to understand who grew up and live here
this is where they've lived this is
where their family members are this is
their communities maybe they own shops
maybe they are have 50 family members or
20 family members this is not an easy
decision to leave we understand that and
what the president is saying is if you
decide to leave next week if you decided
two days ago and we couldn't get you out
we're going to get you out and that's
what his commitment is can i ask about
the immigration system and the refugee
situation
the immigrant the u.s immigration system
is already very overstretched it's
dysfunctional
i wanted to know what steps is the
administration taking
to ensure that the tens of thousands of
afghan people who are being resettled
here in the united states are not going
to be caught up in red tape and that
they're going to get the resources they
need
well first
the president has asked the secretary of
homeland security to lead this effort
and there is a process that includes not
just a thorough background check and
vetting process but as individuals come
to the united states some will end up
going to military bases while they will
help will have access to a range of
resources including vaccines those who
are on who are parolees will be required
to get those vaccines
and what we are working to do is ensure
we are leveraging and working with all
of the incredible refugee resettlement
organizations around the country who are
eager and open to helping these afghan
refugees also to veterans organizations
who are eager and open to helping these
afghan refugees
resettle in the united states and work
through as orderly a process using every
lever of government from the us military
the department of homeland security to
move this process as rapidly as we can
the president was very clear today as he
has been about why he thinks u.s forces
should not be in afghanistan right now
but he was part of the
obama administration in 2014 when the
then president decided he needed to send
troops back to iraq after
several years to deal with serious
does the president
rule out needing to send troops back to
afghanistan they're saying what about
going back they're actually saying what
if we go back in how about that not
going to look into a crystal ball in the
future but i think he's been pretty
clear he doesn't have an intention to
start another war and redeploy troops to
afghanistan what we've seen over the
past week is that
our over the horizon capacity
can work and has worked in going after
isis targets and killing people who went
after our troops
listen now that we got out after 20
years is joe biden thinking maybe we'll
go back in
the i mean ultimately it'll be
ultimately will be up to the president
to decide whether to establish
diplomatic relations with a taliban
only or taliban-led government
and while secretary blinken and others
have have set some of the parameters for
that
does the president himself have a view
about whether it would be appropriate to
ever have a full u.s diplomatic
relationship with taliban well just like
in any circumstance it would depend on
the conditions but there's no rush to
recognition coming from any aspect of
this government or from the
international community
go ahead building on anne's first
question did the president envision any
situation in which he might deploy a
large amount of u.s troops abroad under
his presidency any sort of
the sort of foreign troop deployment
that he just said we are trying to move
fast
i think one of the pieces that he talked
about in the speech was how he views our
engagement in the world and i think this
is probably why you're asking this
question um and the horrible scenes and
memories of the last few weeks and as we
think about
how we embark on or how we use military
force uh these moments and these
divisions of the last several weeks or
months or years should stick in us and
he may stick in our minds he made clear
first we must set missions with clear
achievable goals not ones we will never
reach and second we must stay clearly
focused on the fundamental national
security interests of the united states
i mean the president somebody should
just ask
jen do you know what next war joe biden
has cooked up for us that maybe he'll
start the world he has made very clear
and he said today our work with you
we're not done with you isis that was a
paraphrase but uh he said it better uh
but uh and that i think sends a clear
message that he's going to go after
terrorists he's not going to hesitate to
use the capacities and capabilities we
have but he also wants to be mindful
about how we use uh thousands and large
swaths of troops and i think he was
sending a clear message about how he
views that
second question the president has
obviously been very consumed by this
situation by the hurricane but as we
roll into september should we expect to
start seeing him doing public events
again for his economic agenda
particularly facing the months in
congress that awaits it
absolutely i think you can expect the
president to
be communicating over the coming weeks
on a range of issues that are front and
center on the minds of the american
people certainly he gave a speech today
in afghanistan but
certainly you can expect to hear from
him more on his build back better agenda
on kovit and his commitment to
getting the virus under control uh to
speak to parents and those who have kids
going back to school there are a range
of issues he's eager to communicate
about absolutely go ahead um did the
president watch the takeoff of the last
flight from afghanistan yesterday and
has he been in contact with um you know
any of the service members who were on
the last flight did he watch it uh well
he did i know there's been some
reporting out there on this but i can
confirm for you that
the president learned of the
last flight safely leaving afghanistan
when he was in the oval office meeting
with members of his national security
team and some senior advisors and a note
was passed to his national security
adviser jake sullivan who conveyed it to
the president the news to the president
obviously in those cases for those of
you who have watched these events
closely you have to wait until did
president biden pilot the flight out of
afghanistan or you saw the announcement
by the pentagon um and he
has conveyed repeatedly in meetings that
i have at least been in
to the
military how grateful he is for their
work uh for kind of a weird question
like should he have been watching it i
don't even know it's just strange like
what's the what are you even implying
with that more than 120 000 people in
the middle of a civil war facing isis
threats he's conveyed his gratitude to
them and to the work of his national
security team repeatedly
when does um when does the president
plan to sign the bill that was passed in
the senate today that provides temporary
assistance to americans returning from
afghanistan
i'm sure as soon as possible but i will
have to check
go ahead thanks jen just to go back to
the line of questions from justin you
heard the president say today that he
remains committed to getting those
americans out you said that commitment
remains you said it's an enduring
commitment
you talked about the risk assessment
that's been underway over the last
couple of days or weeks but it was less
than two weeks ago when the president
told abc yes when he was asked are you
committed to making sure troops stay
until every american who wants to get
out gets out he said yes
so obviously situations have changed the
threat increases you've said but
why should those americans believe that
this commitment is enduring when 13 days
ago that commitment changed because he's
evacuated 5 500 american citizens and
their family members and 120 000 total
people over the last two weeks nearly
all of them since that time
but uh you've described the drone
strikes as successful and that america
still has over the horizon capability uh
it appears that several children were
killed in one of the drone strikes ah
now we've got a question that it was
still successful if that was the
collateral damage now we've got a
question
that it has the intelligence necessary
to carry out these drone strikes if
civilians are going to be caught in the
crossfire well first i would say we take
uh civilian casualties and the
possibility of civilian casualties
incredibly seriously in our us military
perhaps more than any other country in
the world there is an investigation and
i don't believe the military or centcom
has spoken to or confirmed what has been
some reporting out there by news
organizations i will note that in
centcom's statement just two nights ago
they made clear that their assessment
was that there was the vehicle that was
the target also had explosiveness in it
and those explosives may have also led
to an impact on the ground but there's
an investigation that's ongoing you're
confident that in the two german drones
like the u.s said terrorists were killed
in both of those strikes
i believe that's the assessment that's
been put out by centcom go ahead april
afghanistan and idaho first i want to
start with ida um
when
katrina happened then president george w
bush
put the gulf coast in a special category
and then president obama as you remember
you were here at that time kept it in
that category for a while to build it
back up are we at that point now
where some parts of the gulf gulf coast
specifically
are new orleans and that area will be
placed in another category to help
rebuild yet again because of the
devastation of ida well april i will say
that we're only on a couple days into
the storm i know you've covered these as
you've referenced in the past and we
don't know how to assess yet all of the
impacts but what i think the people of
the region and the gulf coast should
look at to to to evaluate by the way i
don't want to minimize what is being
alleged about these drone strikes and
that's a good question i want to remind
people
how many kids do you think have been
killed in afghanistan in the last 20
years right and that that does that's
not it's not a justification or a
defense of one thing or the other it's
just people who have not been paying
attention for at least 10 of the last 20
years
now also think they understand the full
scope of what's going on it's a good
question that is a good i'm glad that
was asked but you know there's some
context missing here greg makes the
house the chair of the house
uh foreign affairs committee he said
there will indeed
be congressional hearings on this
longest war in u.s history
from the beginning to this moment
what is the expectation of this
administration when it comes to these
hearings and what are you willing to
offer full transparency as it relates to
how all of this happened beyond these
speeches but going into the weeds as to
why the house the food what when we're
in line
i would say first we've already done
several briefings with members uh
including in the classified setting over
the course of the last several weeks so
that speaks to our commitment to
answering questions they have and uh and
being able to play our role and working
with them on on uh you know addressing
the last seven months now it's a 20-year
war so there's obviously a lot to dig
into
one more yeah but follow up on that but
would you be would you be willing to
would this administration be willing to
sit before hearing some some in this
administration go before congress and
answer questions about their part in
this war again i think we've clearly
already been participating in congress's
asks and we have already been briefing
them there haven't been specific
requests made that i am aware of and as
they come we'll speak to those what are
the embassies in the area doing um in
europe and spain to support this effort
um
to help get americans out and just this
evacuation and going and moving shifting
from the military operation to that of
diplomacy well there there's been a huge
role that our nation's diplomats have
been playing already i think maybe
what's so incongruous about this
is that there's more scrutiny
of the ending of a 20-year war
than there was of the 20-year war that
that i think is like the fundamental
thing here members of the vulnerable
population america from these people
from these people continue and that work
will continue to help get american
citizens and others who have fought by
our side out of the country go ahead
rachel and the president said there's no
deadline to get the remaining americans
who want to leave out of afghanistan but
is there an acceptable timeline for the
president for them coming home
well i would say rachel if someone
decides in a year they want to leave
afghanistan we're going to help them
leave if somebody is now ready to we're
going to help them leave as quickly as
possible so i think that's what he was
conveying
go ahead thanks jen um i want to follow
up on my question yesterday about
deserving afghans who did not get to
leave
i think many people would understand
that in the fog of war despite the best
efforts of the marines and popular
officers on the ground mistakes are made
you know i mean marines could grab
people or push people out of the gate
because of a security threat for example
but what i was talking about were these
specific allegations from
our sources on the ground and people who
are assisting in these rescue operations
who say that because of inconsistent
policies conflicting policies and also a
lack of coordination between the state
department and the pentagon
and also competing interests from people
in washington with influence who are
pulling shrinks
this creates a chaos in which vulnerable
afghans including sivs were left behind
for individuals who may not have a uh
who is not an at-risk individual gets to
leave so is the administration willing
to admit responsibility for this
situation and what would be brighton
said i take responsibility confirmation
of what you've just outlined what i will
tell you is that 117 000 approximately
many of them afghans who people who are
not american citizens were evacuated
that's more people than ever in any
airlift in u.s history and we what our
u.s marines and what our military did on
the ground was work to evacuate as many
people as humanly possible as quickly as
possible and many of those people were
siv applicants many of them were green
card holders obviously we've given you
the number of of american citizens and
many of them were just people from the
vulnerable populations who we were able
to get out but we are committed to
continuing to work in a diplomatic
manner to get more people out who want
to evacuate and i would reiterate that
we've worked already with to
to get support for a statement from 100
countries around the world to pass a u.n
security council resolution and to uh
make clear to the taliban that that's
our expectation yamiche go ahead
can you give us an overall
uh picture of the structure of these
agreements with these countries what are
we paying we're providing them in return
and how we do we deal with local
resentment and this would also apply to
you know people around
american bases who may feel
uh concerned about the threat of either
covet or terrorist threat how are we
dealing with that what we're doing is
we're relying on all of you to convey
clearly what our covet protocols are
what our security protocols are what our
vetting protocols are and we're also
communicating very closely with
governors and leaders in the region
every country has different agreements i
wouldn't this is not a quid pro quo
situation this is where the
international community recognized the
need of the afghan people and nearly two
dozen countries have met this moment to
have a place where uh individuals who
are leaving afghanistan can be some
before they go to third countries some
before they come to the united states
jamish go ahead i think we've got to
move on patsy go ahead um thanks jen
my question the president said that the
u.s should learn from its mistakes in
the past does the president have any
mistakes that he thinks he made during
this withdrawal in afghanistan that he
wants to learn from
well i would say i think the president's
been pretty clear that we all
had an expectation that the afghan
national security forces would fight
harder at the end would fight against
the taliban we all had an expectation
that uh president ghani would not flee
the country
those were not expectations that were
clearly met so you can spend a lot of
time looking in the rearview mirror what
our focus now on is it is on now is
moving forward under our diplomatic
effort settling uh afghan refugees siv
applicants and others who are coming to
the united states doing that in a very
thorough and clear way and also uh
getting them settled in communities
that's what our focus has to be on
that he shouldn't have made those
assumptions about the afghanistan about
the afghan government is that the lesson
for him then i think i think most people
made that uh made that assumption but i
i don't have any more for you
because he said that the u.s should make
them learn from their mistakes but if
there's right and he laid out clearly
what he thinks they are over the past 20
years
yeah louisiana the governor said that
he's worried that the power outages
might start affecting the hospitals um
is there
can you make any clarification on
whether or not um the fema could do
anything more to help
companies
and whether or not there's any sort of
estimates on whether or not hospitals
will be affected well so initial reports
from the local hospital distributor
network indicate no
supply chain disruptions but he is right
i mean this is an area where we are all
watching and this is why we are
continuing to ensure there are necessary
generators there that we are engaged
closely with health administrators and
others about what their needs are and
how we can deliver on them one of the
primary limiting factors um on oxygen
which we don't see a shortage on but is
obviously an issue that we have to watch
closely is actually hazmat certified
drivers and what this is is people who
can who can drive around these oxygen
tanks and and facilities out to the
hospital so there's a number of pieces
that we have to work through
and we are preparing in case there is a
need in that regard
two quick follow-ups yesterday i asked
about the washington post story that
reported that the taliban offered
the united states control of kabul and
instead
it's focused on the airport have you
been able to review that report and is
it accurate well i'm not going to speak
to private conversations but what i will
tell you is that it obviously required
the deployment of six 000 u.s military
forces to secure the airport given the
afghan national security forces uh
collapsed from that protection our
objective has never been and the
president's been very clear about this
having a military presence to control
kabul so that's never been our objective
um
you've talked about how our commitment
remains to these americans and uh we
talked about how we're switching from a
military effort to a diplomatic effort
for the americans who are currently in
hiding and who very much want to come
home not the other set
what is the administration's message to
them should they
try and head to the border should they
try and book a flight out of there or
should they remain in hiding
and hope that the diplomacy kicks in
well i would just note that we are in
touch with a number of these americans
not everyone perhaps but we are in touch
we may be we are in touch with as many
of them who we can make contact with
through a range of means that continues
and what our focus is on now and we'll
have day by day updates and this is a
very fair and good question is
how can we ensure operationally that
there are a range of options for
people to be able to depart some of that
may be over land over borders
some of that may be through
airplanes and so we're working again
with the cutteries and the turks on that
we're working to get the civilian side
of the airport operational but those are
all pieces we're focused on i always
thought it was the qataris not the
cutteries
worst case scenario in some
circumstances hostage situations
look our focus right now is on making
clear to the taliban and to others in
afghanistan that uh we are going to get
these americans citizens out that we are
going to hold them to that account and
that's our focus thanks everyone
i i'll be back tomorrow
[Applause]
mask and exit there for jen saki and
that is the conclusion of today's press
briefing
all right thanks everybody very very
strong double stream today couldn't
couldn't be better quite frankly really
couldn't be better
and tomorrow 1 pm east 10 a.m west i
will be joined by dr alok kenosha
a psychiatrist we will be doing an
intervention with jimmy from philly
that's tomorrow
one p e
10 p w
decode that if you will
that will also be
7 pm central
european time
all right see everybody tomorrow